programming throwdown episode 69 puzzle games take it away mark and patrick hi everyone uh we're here with Mark Engelberg, puzzle inventor. Nice. Mark, why don't you start off by telling us a little bit about yourself, your background, and what you're up to. Hi, it's great to be here. I studied computer science and cognitive science at Rice University. And somewhere in the middle of my sophomore year of college, I read an article about virtual reality. This was in the very early 1990s. So there weren't many people doing virtual
Programming Throwdown 第69期：益智游戏。Mark 和 Patrick，开始吧。大家好，我们请到了益智游戏发明家 Mark Engelberg。太棒了。Mark，不如先向大家介绍一下你自己、你的背景以及你最近在忙些什么。大家好，很高兴来到这里。我在莱斯大学学习计算机科学和认知科学。在大二那年的某个时候，我读到了一篇关于虚拟现实的文章。那是在 20 世纪 90 年代初，当时从事虚拟现实研究的人并不多。
reality. There weren't many people talking about it. But I read an article and I thought, wow, this sounds awesome. I want to be a part of this i i'd kind of grown up playing adventure games uh text adventure games oh like zork like zork yeah colossal cave those kinds of things uh and then transition transitioned when text adventure games kind of uh became graphical adventure games like by sierra for example yes king's quest and space Quest and Leisure Suit Larry and all those games. Yeah, Police Quest. They were just wonderful games. And I loved those kinds of games, that melding of story and puzzles. And to me, virtual reality was the obvious next step for this kind of stuff. And of course, I also grew up watching star trek next generation with the holodeck and everything and i i was convinced that you know someday there's going to be this
谈论它的人也很少。但我读了那篇文章后觉得，哇，这听起来太棒了。我想参与其中。我从小就玩冒险游戏，比如文字冒险游戏，像《魔域》(Zork)、《巨洞冒险》(Colossal Cave) 之类的。后来，当文字冒险游戏逐渐演变成图形冒险游戏时，比如 Sierra 公司出品的游戏，我就跟着转型了。是的，比如《国王密使》(King's Quest)、《太空密使》(Space Quest) 和《休闲西装拉里》(Leisure Suit Larry) 等等。没错，还有《警察故事》(Police Quest)。它们都是非常棒的游戏。我热爱那种游戏，那种故事与谜题的融合。对我来说，虚拟现实是这类游戏显而易见的下一步。当然，我也从小看《星际迷航：下一代》，里面有全息甲板之类的东西，我当时深信，总有一天会有一个
studio where they're going to be making these virtual reality adventure games for people to play and you know i want to be the steven spielberg of virtual reality so i uh read all about this and i thought i got to get into this industry so i and of course i called my parents from college and i said oh i figured out what i want to do i want to do virtual reality they'd never heard of it and they're just okay sure well actually i grew up in kind of a small town and we had a virtual reality like uh i don't know what you would call it. It was kind of like an arcade, but it just had this one thing. And they charged $10 for about two minutes. And it was the frame rate was like three FPS. Yeah, yeah. And it was just, but it was a pterodactyl one. Was that the pterodactyl one? The only part I really remember was you're in an an elevator an elevator is kind of rising up and
工作室，他们会制作这些虚拟现实冒险游戏供人们游玩。你知道，我想成为虚拟现实界的史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格。所以我读了所有相关资料，心想我一定要进入这个行业。于是，我从大学给父母打电话说：“哦，我找到我想做的事了，我想做虚拟现实。”他们从没听说过这个，只是说：“好吧，当然。”其实我是在一个小镇长大的，我们那里有一个虚拟现实设备，我不知道该怎么称呼它。它有点像街机，但只有一个游戏。玩两分钟要收 10 美元。帧率大概只有 3 帧每秒。是的，没错。它只是……但那是一个翼龙游戏。是那个翼龙游戏吗？我唯一记得的部分是你坐在一台电梯里，电梯正在上升，然后
you're having to kind of shoot i don't even remember what i if it's the one i'm thinking of and it might not be but if it's the one i'm thinking of there was a popular one uh at arcade places like dave and busters that had you kind of riding up and down platforms, shooting at pterodactyls flying. It might be that one, yeah. Yeah, so I took all the money I had saved up from a couple summers jobs and flew out to a virtual reality conference. I found that one that was happening in the Bay Area, and I spent all my money to get out there and made contacts with people in the industry. I mean, it was unusual, this college student kind of showing up at this virtual reality conference.
你必须射击……我甚至不记得是不是我想的那一个，可能不是。但如果是我记忆中的那个，在 Dave & Busters 这样的街机厅里很流行，你需要上下移动平台，射击飞行的翼龙。可能就是那个。是的，所以我用打了几份暑期工攒下的钱，飞去参加了一个虚拟现实会议。我找到了在湾区举办的那场会议，花光了所有的钱去那里，并结识了业内人士。说实话，一个大学生出现在虚拟现实会议上确实很不寻常。
But people kind of remembered me and were impressed that I had taken the initiative to come to the conference. And so the following summer, I went through my business cards and kind of called that I'd collected and called different people. And it turned out that one of the guys I'd spoken with was now the director of the virtual reality lab at NASA.
但人们记住了我，并对我主动参加会议的行为印象深刻。所以第二年夏天，我翻看我收集的名片，给不同的人打了电话。结果发现，我交谈过的一个人现在是 NASA 虚拟现实实验室的主任。
And he offered me a summer job, which then turned into a full-time job as soon as I graduated. And I was one of the original pioneers in virtual reality. I had the luxury of working with these million-dollar computers. It literally took, back then, a half-a-million-dollar computer to power the graphics for each eye. Oh, wow. So a total of a million dollars of graphics power to power the whole virtual reality headset graphics.
他给了我一份暑期工作，毕业后又转成了全职工作。我是虚拟现实领域的先驱之一。我有幸使用那些价值百万美元的计算机。在当时，要为每只眼睛提供图形渲染，确实需要一台价值五十万美元的计算机。哇，太惊人了。所以总共需要一百万美元的图形处理能力来驱动整个虚拟现实头显的画面。
So you can understand why there weren't that many places where you could work on virtual reality. And the lab that I was working in was involved with training, specifically training the astronauts and more importantly, training the ground crew. Because the astronauts have a lot training the ground crew because the astronauts have a lot of hands-on training they can do they can get into a pool underwater and manipulate objects you know to simulate a space mission when i was there the big space mission that was coming up was the hubble space telescope repair mission and there's a ton of ground crew, though, that needs to sit there following through the procedure and talking to the astronaut, walking them through it, having all these contingency plans if anything goes wrong. And it's really hard to train people on memorizing
所以你可以理解为什么当时能从事虚拟现实工作的地方并不多。我工作的实验室主要负责培训，特别是培训宇航员，更重要的是培训地面人员。因为宇航员有大量的实践训练，他们可以进入水下模拟池，操纵物体来模拟太空任务。我在那里时，即将进行的重大太空任务是哈勃太空望远镜维修任务。虽然有大量的地面人员需要坐在那里，遵循操作程序并与宇航员沟通，引导他们完成任务，并制定各种应急预案以防万一。要让人记住
a whole bunch of dry procedures. And so we thought, hey, we can take virtual reality and people can go into the virtual reality world and kind of be the astronauts and fix the Hubble Space Telescope repair mission themselves. And I'll bet that that will cause them to remember the procedures a lot better than if they just try to memorize it out of the book. And so that's what we were doing. We were kind of trying to be the first people to prove that virtual reality was actually useful for something. And it turned out it was. It really did help people have better recall.
一大堆枯燥的程序真的很难。所以我们想，嘿，我们可以利用虚拟现实，让人们进入虚拟世界，亲自扮演宇航员去完成哈勃太空望远镜的维修任务。我敢打赌，这会让他们比单纯从书本上死记硬背更好地记住这些程序。这就是我们当时在做的事情。我们试图成为第一批证明虚拟现实确实有实际用途的人。事实证明确实如此，它确实帮助人们提高了记忆力。
So do you know how to fix the Hubble telescope? I still remember a lot of the details, surprisingly, years later. But yeah, it was pretty neat. And as part of that team, I was part of a lot of virtual reality firsts. I'm pretty sure I wrote the first real-time 3D physics engine, I think. I built a virtual reality physics lab where you could manipulate the magnitude and direction of gravity, for example, with a dial on the wall and then bounce the ball in the room and watch it fly in all kinds of crazy directions based on what you had set the gravity to.
所以你知道怎么修理哈勃望远镜吗？令人惊讶的是，多年后我仍然记得很多细节。但确实，那段经历很棒。作为团队的一员，我参与了许多虚拟现实的“第一次”。我很确定我编写了第一个实时 3D 物理引擎。我建立了一个虚拟现实物理实验室，你可以通过墙上的旋钮来操纵重力的大小和方向，然后让球在房间里弹跳，观察它根据你设置的重力以各种疯狂的方式飞行。
Wow. So you actually did like the Verlet integration and applying the torque and collisions and all of that? Yes. You wrote it all in assembly or something? A lot of the stuff was done in C. Okay. But NASA had their own special language for building expert systems called CLPS. And they used that for a lot of detailed simulations where you have tons of rules you need to pattern
哇。所以你真的做了 Verlet 积分，并应用了扭矩、碰撞检测等等？是的。你是用汇编语言或者其他什么写的吗？很多东西是用 C 语言完成的。好的。但 NASA 有他们自己用于构建专家系统的特殊语言，叫做 CLPS。他们用它进行许多详细的模拟，其中有大量的规则需要进行模式
match on. And it was a language kind of optimized for that. And I did a lot of research on how that language was kind of a particularly useful paradigm for building simulations like in virtual reality. So that was something I've always been really interested in programming languages and how different languages cause you to think in different ways and cause certain problems to be easier or harder to solve. And so I was really excited to be working with this unusual programming language and looking at how it made certain kinds of simulation programming to be more accessible.
匹配。这是一种为此优化的语言。我做了很多研究，探讨这种语言作为构建虚拟现实模拟的范式为何特别有用。所以我一直对编程语言非常感兴趣，研究不同的语言如何让你以不同的方式思考，并使某些问题变得更容易或更难解决。所以我非常兴奋能使用这种不同寻常的编程语言，并研究它如何让某些类型的模拟编程变得更容易实现。
So that was a lot of what I did at NASA. We also did, I think we did the first over the internet virtual reality, like a teleconferencing internet with another NASA. So it was a fun time. But a couple years into that, I realized that virtual reality wasn't going to be changing much for a very long time. It was just going to gradually, gradually get cheaper. And as long as it was a million dollars to power some goggles, it was going to be a long way off before my dream actually happened, if it was ever going to happen.
这就是我在 NASA 所做的大部分工作。我们还进行了我认为是第一次跨互联网的虚拟现实演示，就像是与其他 NASA 部门进行的远程会议。那是一段有趣的时光。但几年后，我意识到虚拟现实在很长一段时间内都不会有太大改变。它只会逐渐、逐渐地变得便宜。只要驱动护目镜仍需要一百万美元，我的梦想距离实现还有很长的路要走，如果它真的能实现的话。
So just before you go i should interject what do you think about the state of vr now like now you uh i haven't tried it but i think you can just if you have a samsung phone you can just attach it to this this head mounted display and strap it to your head and you have basically yeah i have done that with my phone, actually. And I've also, I go to virtual reality meetups here in the Seattle area. And I've had a chance, I don't personally own any of the new VR setups, but I have had a chance to try most of them. And it really is astonishing how far the graphics have come. There's no question. I mean, what you can do with an inexpensive computer now is miles better than what we were able to do with a million dollars of computing
在你继续之前，我应该插一句，你觉得现在 VR 的状态如何？现在你……我还没试过，但我想如果你有一部三星手机，你就可以把它装进头戴式显示器里，绑在头上，基本上就……是的，我确实用我的手机试过。我也去过西雅图地区的虚拟现实聚会。我有机会尝试过大多数新的 VR 设备，虽然我个人没有购买。图形技术的发展确实令人震惊，这是毫无疑问的。我的意思是，现在用一台廉价计算机能做到的事情，比我们 20 年、25、26 年前用一百万美元的计算
power 20 years ago, 25, six years ago. So it really is astonishing how far things have come. But what's fascinating to me is that even back then when the graphics were crude, the sense of immersion was so compelling and so powerful. So it feels really familiar. I've logged so many hours in virtual worlds that for me it just feels familiar and natural when I get back in a virtual reality environment. It just feels exactly how I remember it, kind of. Just it looks better and the what was I gonna say um so you're talking about uh transitioning from VR to your next industry right so I realized it was going to take a while to kind of get to where things are right now where people have access to this stuff
能力所能做到的要好得多。所以事情的发展确实令人惊叹。但令我着迷的是，即使在当时图形很粗糙的情况下，沉浸感依然是如此引人入胜且强大。所以它感觉非常熟悉。我在虚拟世界中投入了太多时间，以至于对我来说，当我回到虚拟现实环境中时，感觉非常熟悉和自然。它感觉就像我记忆中的那样。只是画面更好，而且……我要说什么来着？嗯，所以你在谈论从 VR 转型到下一个行业，对吧？所以我意识到，要达到人们现在可以在家里使用这些东西的程度还需要一段时间。
at home and so i realized that if i was going to pursue this vision i had in college of doing entertainment vr the next thing i needed to do was get into the entertainment industry so my wife and i kind of looked around at different parts of the country this we were in houston because that's where john Space Center was. That's where I worked. But we figured it was time to settle down somewhere, kind of looked around where in the country we wanted to live, where the hot tech spots. And I was specifically interested in where is the next kind of gaming boom where can i work on computer games and i we decided on moving to the seattle area and coincidentally that was when sierra online the the company whose adventure games i had grown up playing king's quest space quest leisure suit larry they were founded by a husband wife team in Oakhurst, California, just near Yosemite.
所以我意识到，如果我想追求我在大学时拥有的娱乐 VR 的愿景，我接下来需要做的是进入娱乐行业。我和妻子考察了全国不同的地方。当时我们在休斯顿，因为约翰逊航天中心在那里，那是我工作的地方。但我们觉得是时候在某个地方定居了，我们考察了全国想住的地方，哪里是热门的科技中心。我特别感兴趣的是下一个游戏热潮在哪里，我可以在哪里从事计算机游戏工作。我们决定搬到西雅图地区。巧合的是，就在那时，Sierra Online——我从小玩着他们的冒险游戏（《国王密使》、《太空密使》、《休闲西装拉里》）长大的那家公司——是由一对夫妻在加州奥克赫斯特（靠近优胜美地）创立的。
And they had just opened. They had all relocated to Seattle and opened an office here on the east side of Seattle, uh, in Bellevue. And I was the first programmer Sierra online hired here in Bellevue. So I was living my dream working with these adventure game designers that I had grown up playing. One of the first big projects I worked on was a family
他们刚刚搬迁到西雅图，并在西雅图东区的贝尔维尤开设了办公室。我是 Sierra Online 在贝尔维尤雇佣的第一位程序员。所以我实现了我的梦想，与我从小玩着他们的游戏长大的那些冒险游戏设计师一起工作。我参与的第一个大项目是一个家庭
game called Torrance Passage written by Al Lowe, famous for the Leisure Suit Larry series. And he is as hilarious in real life as you might imagine if you've ever had a chance to play his games. And it was just a fun environment to work in. And I really enjoyed it. I eventually moved into game design and started writing my own ideas for Sierra. But then the bottom kind of fell out of the adventure game market. And Sierra, I think, got sold to some other company. And things were kind of fell out of the adventure game market and Sierra, I think got sold to some other company and things were kind of falling apart
游戏，叫《Torrance Passage》，由 Al Lowe 编写，他因《休闲西装拉里》系列而闻名。他在现实生活中和你玩过他游戏后想象的一样风趣。那是一个非常有趣的工作环境，我真的很喜欢。我最终转到了游戏设计领域，并开始为 Sierra 撰写我自己的创意。但随后冒险游戏市场崩溃了，Sierra 似乎被卖给了另一家公司。事情在 Sierra 变得有些分崩离析。
at Sierra. So I figured that was a good time to get into computer games as you know, the underlying technology that powers computer games. Cause I don't know, do either of you have experience working in the game industry or not? I don't remember. No, I've experienced playing a lot of different games but not working in the industry.
所以我认为那是进入计算机游戏底层技术领域的好时机。因为我不知道，你们俩有在游戏行业工作的经验吗？我不记得了。没有，我有玩过很多不同游戏的经验，但没有在行业内工作过。
So one thing your listeners might be interested to know is that in the game industry it's pretty common to have kind of a separation of skills between the people who kind of write the game engines and the people who write the logic of the games. And I especially, I have to say, I especially loved writing the logic of the games and not worrying about the engine stuff. That was kind of, to me, that was just the purity of what programming... Programming to me has always been about the fun of creating this virtual world that you can explore all through programming. You can create anything you can imagine.
所以听众可能感兴趣的一点是，在游戏行业，负责编写游戏引擎的人和负责编写游戏逻辑的人之间通常有技能上的分工。我必须说，我特别喜欢编写游戏逻辑，而不必担心引擎方面的事情。对我来说，那才是编程的纯粹之处……对我而言，编程一直是为了创造一个可以通过编程探索的虚拟世界的乐趣。你可以创造任何你能想象到的东西。
And it's fun for me when the engine's already written and I can just sit and concentrate on building that world. That is really fun for me that's interesting I actually I feel personally just the opposite and the reason is and it depends obviously on the game but a lot of games are kind of um like like uh induct the law the goombas kind of move the same way and you have to sort of put them in a certain way where the player will execute a certain pattern
当引擎已经写好，我可以坐下来专注于构建那个世界时，这对我来说很有趣。这真的很有趣。这很有意思，我个人的感觉恰恰相反。原因在于——当然这取决于游戏——很多游戏有点像……比如栗宝宝（Goombas）的移动方式是一样的，你必须以某种方式放置它们，让玩家执行特定的模式。
but I don't I mean maybe it's just because I've never really done it but I always felt to me like that part was inductive like you would just put them kind of anywhere and then you would see what the player does and then move them a little bit and it felt like the engine you know if you could make something like the engine was a little bit
但我并不是说……也许只是因为我从未真正做过，但我一直觉得那部分是归纳式的。就像你可以把它们随便放在哪里，然后看看玩家怎么做，再稍微移动一下它们。感觉如果引擎……你知道，如果你能让引擎更具程序化或生成性……
more procedural or generative um but it might be because you know i think maybe after time maybe you get a handle on sort of the artistic part of it and you could kind of maybe predict that in advance yeah i mean there's there's certainly slightly different skills and appeal to different people so i mean i think that's great that there are people like you that really love working at that lower level um i did it for a while because i wanted that experience i worked worked at a couple different companies, but one was Rad Game Tools. And Rad Game Tools is famous for the Bink video compression. And that's used in just a ton of video games. And I was one of the first employees there
但可能是因为，我想也许随着时间的推移，你掌握了其中的艺术部分，你就能提前预判了。是的，确实存在略有不同的技能，对不同的人有不同的吸引力。所以我认为有像你这样真正喜欢在底层工作的人是很棒的。我做过一段时间，因为我想要那种经验。我在几家不同的公司工作过，其中一家是 Rad Game Tools。Rad Game Tools 以 Bink 视频压缩技术而闻名，它被用在大量的视频游戏中。我是那里的第一批员工之一，
other than the founder of the company. And I helped do a lot of that early work in researching and designing the algorithms that powered the the bink video compression system cool yeah i'm sure i mean so people who are listening at home uh you know start any video game if you're a gamer start the game look at the splash screen right at the beginning you know kind of search you know there's a screen in the beginning which has all the copyright and, you know, maybe the logo, but a bunch of other things.
除了公司创始人之外。我帮助完成了许多早期的研究工作，并设计了驱动 Bink 视频压缩系统的算法。酷。是的，我相信……所以听众朋友们，如果你是玩家，启动任何视频游戏，看看刚开始的启动画面。你知道，搜索一下……开始时有一个屏幕，上面有版权信息，可能还有 Logo，以及其他一些东西。
I guarantee you almost any game you'll see this, it's like a, it almost looks like, you can probably describe it better than I can, but it's like a tornado, but it's made out of different bands of color. That's the Bink video logo, and you'll see it almost anywhere.
我敢保证，几乎在任何游戏中你都会看到这个。它看起来几乎像……你可能比我描述得更好，但它就像一个龙卷风，由不同的色带组成。那就是 Bink 视频的 Logo，你几乎随处可见。
Yeah, and I think what I loved the most about that job was it gave me a chance to really use my math background. I mean, I've always been really deep into math, and programming is kind of connected to math, but not necessarily on an everyday basis, depending on what you're doing. And certainly when I was doing high level logic for adventure games I'm not really using math on a daily basis and it was really interesting for me to kind of get back to my math roots in that job and
是的，我想我最喜欢那份工作的原因是它让我有机会真正利用我的数学背景。我的意思是，我一直深入研究数学，编程与数学是相连的，但并不一定每天都在使用，这取决于你在做什么。当然，当我在做冒险游戏的高级逻辑时，我并没有每天使用数学。在那份工作中重新回到数学根源对我来说非常有趣，
read up read through papers on compression theory and information theory and figure out how to implement these things. At the time, just to give people a sense for what computers were like at that time when we were developing Bink Video Compression, MP3s, right now MP3s are ubiquitous. But back then, if you wanted to play an MP3, it would pretty much consume your entire CPU of your computer to play back mp3 it would pretty much consume your entire cpu of your computer to play back that mp3 i remember uh yeah there's this uh the song um the men in black theme song for the very first
阅读压缩理论和信息论的论文，并弄清楚如何实现这些东西。当时，为了让大家了解我们开发 Bink 视频压缩时计算机是什么样子，MP3 在现在随处可见。但在当时，如果你想播放一个 MP3，它几乎会消耗掉你计算机的全部 CPU 来播放……我记得……是的，有那首《黑衣人》的主题曲，那是我的第一个 MP3。我双击它，或者把它拖进 Winamp 之类的软件里，我的电脑就死机了，鼠标都动不了。我什么也做不了。我只能听《黑衣人》。就是这样。等歌放完，我才能再次移动鼠标。是的，我早期是 MP3 格式的忠实拥护者。
men in black that was the first mp3 i had and i double clicked it or i dragged it into i think winamp or something and my computer froze like i couldn't move the mouse. I couldn't do anything. I just had to listen to Men in Black. That was it. And then when the song finished, then I could move my mouse again. Yeah. I was a big believer in the MP3 format early on.
我创建了最早的 MP3 分享网站之一，专门试图将独立艺术家与想听独立音乐的人联系起来。但我因为资金耗尽而无法继续运营该网站，因为它没有获得很多下载量，因为人们的机器里没有内置 MP3 播放器，你必须下载专门的播放器，而且它会消耗你所有的 CPU。我想我在那方面稍微超前了一点。在我放弃那个项目几年后，MP3 才真正作为主流消费音乐的方式爆发了。但在我们离开关于构建游戏引擎和设计游戏之间二分法的话题之前，我想……我之前可能把它作为节目推荐书提过，但《Doom 之父》(Masters of Doom) 这本书回顾了 id Software 的历史，它与 Sierra Online 和冒险游戏有很多交集。
I created one of the first MP3 sharing websites specifically to try to connect indie artists with people who wanted to listen to indie music and it was i i kind of ran out of money to fund the website because it wasn't getting a lot of downloads because people did not have mp3 players built into their machine you had to download special players for that and it then consumed all your cpu and i was just a little bit ahead of the curve i think on that and it was a couple years after i gave up on that that mp3s really exploded as kind of the mainstream consumer way to to to consume music but before we leave the topic of the you know sort of
卡马克 (Carmack) 和罗梅罗 (Romero) 作为游戏设计师和引擎程序员之间的平衡，在书中得到了详细的体现。所以，正如 Jason 提到的，如果你感兴趣，那确实是一本好书。它读起来很容易，而且据我所知，它不是虚构的，而是对 id Software（制作《德军总部 3D》和《毁灭战士》的那些人）生动的讲述，很多我们可能都记得那些游戏。是的，很有趣，即使
dichotomy between building game engines and designing games i will uh i think i've had it as a book of the show before but masters of doom which is sort of a a kind of review of the id software uh has a lot of intertwining with sierra online and the adventure games um and then the sort of counterbalance between uh carmack and romero uh as sort of game designer and engine programmer uh plays out in great detail through that book and so to you know jason was sort of mentioning some about it and you were too that you know i think if if people are interested in that that's actually a really good read it's it's pretty easy uh and as far as I know it's not fictional but uh it's a lively telling of the the id software the guys who made Wolfenstein 3d and doom uh and a lot of those games that a lot of us probably remember yeah it's funny even
我喜欢视频游戏和 3D 技术，但我从未真正进入《毁灭战士》阶段，原因有两个。第一，当时我坐在价值百万美元的计算机上玩 3D 环境。所以我有点看不起像《毁灭战士》这样只在 PC 上玩的游戏。另一个原因是，我想我也有点怨恨像《毁灭战士》这样的游戏，因为它们在某种程度上扼杀了冒险游戏。看起来人们失去了对谜题沉浸感的兴趣，转而追求射击沉浸体验。这可能并不准确。
though I'm into video games and I'm into 3D stuff, I never really got into the whole Doom phase for two reasons. One was because at the time I was sitting playing in 3D environments on million dollar computers. So I kind of turned up my nose at these games like Doom that were just played on a PC. And the other thing was I also, I think, a little bit resented games like Doom as kind of the killers of adventure games in a way. It seemed like people lost their taste for the puzzle immersion things in favor of shooter immersion experiences. That's probably not inaccurate.
是的，我的意思是，更深入到脑干了，对吧？是的，我想我对此怀恨在心有一段时间了。所以我认为出于这两个原因，我从未真正迷上《毁灭战士》。但它无疑是一个极其受欢迎的领域，如果那本书是关于这类事情的绝佳资源，我一点也不会感到惊讶。但我关于压缩想说的一点是，如果解码压缩会消耗你所有的 CPU，那你怎么能在游戏中放入这样的东西呢？
Yeah, I mean, further down in the brainstem, right? Yeah, I think I had a little bit of a grudge about that for a while. So I think for both of those reasons i i never quite got into the doom thing but i certainly it's an incredibly popular field and i i would not be surprised if that book you described is a great resource for that kind of thing but the the point i was going to make about compression was that if decoding that compression is consuming all your CPU, how are you going to put something like that in a game, right?
在你的游戏中，有很多事情在同时发生。你想要播放背景音乐。也许在背景音乐之上，还有一层人声或角色配音。甚至你可能还想在屏幕上放一个小视频面板。如果这些压缩任务中的每一个都要占用你所有的 CPU，你该怎么做？这就是 Rad Game Tools 这样的公司发挥作用的地方。他们意识到压缩技术存在一个特殊的利基市场，也许压缩需要更长的时间，也许它
In your game, you've got all kinds of stuff going on. And you want to have a soundtrack playing. And maybe on top of that, a layer of some voices or character voices. And maybe you even want a little video panel in the screen. And how do you do that if each of these compression things is going to take all your CPUs? That's where a company like Rad Game Tools comes in. They realized there was this specialized niche for compression technology that maybe it takes a longer time to compress it and maybe it doesn't
甚至压缩得不是那么好，但解码速度极快。通过做出这种权衡，并优化解码的速度和低 CPU 使用率，他们能够解决整个视频游戏行业需要但其他人并没有真正解决的利基需求。这就是我所做的。我会坐下来，阅读 MP3 的工作原理。然后我会写出一些东西，可能比 MP3 稍微差一点，不是在音质方面，而是在压缩率方面，但播放速度比 MP3 快一百万倍。太棒了。
even compress it quite as well but the decoding is incredibly fast and by making that trade-off and optimizing for the speed and and low cpu usage of decoding they were able to address this entire niche that the whole video gaming industry needed, but that no one else was really addressing. And so that's what I would do. I would sit and, you know, I'd go read about how MP3s worked. And then I would sit down and write something that was, you know, maybe a little crappier than MP3, but not in terms of sound quality, but in terms of how much it would compress and would play back a million times faster than an MP3 would. Nice.
然后对视频也做了同样的事情。但音频压缩是视频压缩的一个子集，因为你也必须压缩音轨。那么，说你的第一门编程语言是 NASA 的那个……NASA 的那个叫什么来着？那个专家系统语言？CLIPS。有趣的是，我在 Sierra 工作的那几年，他们也有自己的编程语言来编写所有这些高级冒险游戏。
And then did the same thing for video. But audio compression is kind of a subset of video compression because you've got to compress the soundtrack also. So would it be fair to say your first programming language was the NASA? What was the NASA one called again? The expert system one? Clips. And interestingly, Sierra, where I worked for a couple of years, had their own programming language, too, to write all these high level adventure games.
在大学里，我学的第一门编程语言是 Scheme，它是 Lisp 的一种方言。然后我们立即转而使用 C++，并在大学剩下的几年里一直使用它。所以我因为 C++ 技能被很多公司录用。但讽刺的是，我工作的每个地方都有这些特定领域的语言，它们的工作方式很像 Scheme 和 Lisp。我使用它们的原因是，Scheme 是第一种易于嵌入的解释型语言之一。如今我们有很多选择，比如 Lua 作为嵌入式语言在编写视频游戏逻辑方面非常流行，因为它作为高层逻辑层嵌入在底层引擎之上。
In college, I had learned as my first programming language scheme, which is a dialect of Lisp. And then we immediately transitioned to using C++ and kind of used C++ for the rest of our college years. And so I got hired at a lot of these jobs for my C++ skills. But then ironically, everywhere I worked, they had these domain specific languages that worked a lot like Scheme and Lisp. And I was using and the reason for that is because Scheme was one of the first easily kind of embeddable interpreted languages. These days we have a lot of choices, like Lua is really popular as an embedded language for scripting video game logic, because it can be embedded as a high level layer to write your logic on top of a low level engine.
它在处理这类事情方面非常出色。但在当时，如果你想创建一种特定领域的语言来赋能你的程序员，你通常会把它写成 Lisp 的一种方言，因为每个人都明白如何解析 Lisp，如何解释 Lisp 程序。我的意思是，这是一个足够简单的练习，很多大学课程都会让你把它作为一个练习。所以当时有太多的工具了。比如如果你去买一个 CAD 系统或其他东西来进行 3D 建模，内置的脚本语言就是某种 Lisp 方言。
It does that kind of thing really well. But back then, if you wanted to create a language, a domain specific language to empower your programmers, you would typically write it as a dialect of Lisp because everybody understood how you parse Lisp, how you interpret a Lisp program. I mean, it's a simple enough exercise that a lot of college classes would have you do that as an exercise. And so there were so many tools back then. Like if you went out and got a CAD system or whatever to do 3D modeling, the built-in scripting language was some dialect of Lisp.
大多数工具，如果你想能够编程，它们都会包含某种 Lisp 层，某种类似 Scheme 的层，供你作为程序员进行脚本编写。讽刺的是，我主要是因为 C++ 技能被录用，但在很多工作中，我最终基本上都在做 Scheme 和 Lisp 编程，或者实际上是在使用他们自己的语言。这很有道理。这解释了你对函数式语言的热情。你现在最喜欢的语言是什么？嗯，我非常喜欢 Clojure 语言，并且已经成为该社区非常活跃的成员。我在 Closure 达到 1.0 版本时就开始将其作为我的主要编程语言。我通过 Python 接触到它。我从 C++ 转过来。然后在 Rad Game Tools 之后，我的儿子出生了，我决定我想成为那个留在家照顾孩子的人。所以我待在家里。
Most tools, if you wanted to be able to program it, they would include some kind of Lisp layer, some scheme-like layer for you as the programmer to do that scripting. It was just ironic that I was hired mainly for my C++ skills, and in a lot of these jobs I ended up basically doing scheme and Lisp programming programming or effectively in their own languages. That makes sense. And so that kind of explains the sort of, um, your, your sort of passion for functional languages. Like what would you say is your, your favorite language now? Well, I am really into the language Clojure and I've become a very active member of that community. I started using Closure as my primary programming language back when it turned 1.0. I kind of came at that through Python. I kind of went from C++. And then after Rad Game Tools, my son was born and I decided I wanted to be the one to stay home with my kids. And so I was at home.
我做了很多年的全职爸爸。我想开始做一些我自己的编程项目。我也想也许接一些合同工作。我必须考虑哪种编程语言能给我个人带来最大的生产力。我发现，C++ 是我受过最多训练的语言，但在某种程度上，C++ 程序……我可以编写非常快的 C++ 程序，但构建它们需要很长时间。我习惯于在 Sierra 作为大团队的一部分来构建它们，虽然我在那里并没有做 C++ 编程。但我通常习惯于在像 Sierra 那样拥有大预算的大团队中工作。在那个时代，一款冒险游戏的开发成本通常是一百万美元。
I was the stay-at-home dad for many years. And I wanted to start doing some of my own programming projects. And I also wanted to perhaps pick up some contracting jobs. And I had to think about what programming language would give me the maximum productivity as an individual. And what I was finding, you know, C++ was what I had one of, you know, to some degree, the most training in. But C++ programs, like I could make really fast C++ programs, but it would take me a long time to build them. I was used to building them as part of big teams at Sierra when we well, I wasn't doing C++ programming there. But I was in general used to working on big teams with big budgets like at Sierra. It was very typical in that era for an adventure game to cost a million dollars to build.
你有一个由程序员、动画师、艺术家、测试人员甚至艺术技术人员组成的团队，他们的主要工作只是将一种文件格式转换为另一种格式并使用一些工具。但我习惯了那种工作流程。我发现当我尝试在家庭项目中使用 C++ 时，构建东西花费的时间太长了。所以正如我所说，我一直是一个编程语言爱好者，一直在尝试新语言，尝试新事物。第一门让我产生共鸣的语言是 Python，因为我发现它虽然不如 C 语言快，但在它足够快的领域里，我构建东西的速度要快得多。
You have a team of programmers and animators and artists and testers and even art techs whose main job is just to convert one file format to another and use some of the tools. But I was used to that kind of working process. And what I was finding is that when I would try to use C++ for my home projects, it was taking me too long to build things. So like I said, I've always been a programming language person, always out there trying new languages, trying new things. And one of the first ones to strike a chord with me was Python because I found it wasn't as fast as C, but for the things that it was fast enough for, I could build things way faster.
这是因为它内置了一套非常丰富的数据结构。使用这些数据结构以不同的方式组合它们来构建你需要的东西非常容易，而不必做大量的自定义数据结构工作。你可以直接使用语言内置的那些。但我同时发现自己对 Python 有点不满意。
And that's because it has a really rich set of data structures built into it. And it's just so easy to use those data structures to kind of combine them in different ways to build whatever you need to build without having to do a lot of custom data structure work. You can just use the ones built into the language. But I found myself a little dissatisfied with Python at the same time.
这种不满的一部分来自于我怀念函数式编程中带来的一些不可变性原则。我可能应该为那些不太了解的人解释一下，函数式编程是关于函数，并以函数作为你组合在一起的主要组件的方式构建程序。但我认为函数式编程重要的地方在于，它主要处理我所说的纯函数，意味着对于给定的输入集，总是返回相同的输出。它是非常可预测的。我们在其他编程语言中编写的大多数函数都在改变某些东西，或者破坏性地改变某个对象的值，
And part of that dissatisfaction came from that I missed some of the immutability principles that come with functional programming. And I should probably explain that a little bit for people who aren't as understand that functional programming is about, well, is about functions and building your program in a way where functions are kind of the primary components that you're composing together. But what I think is the important thing about functional programming is that it mostly deals with what I would call pure functions, meaning something that for a given set of inputs always returns the same output. It's very predictable. Most of the things we write in other programming languages have most functions we write are mutating something or they're changing the value of something, some kind of object destructively
或者更新某个哈希表的内容，或者……一切通常都是一种破坏性的思维方式。当你那样构建程序时，你的函数就不是纯函数。这对我来说在智力上是不满足的。我的意思是，当你做 2 加 3 时，你并没有销毁数字 2 并用 5 代替它。所以我想要那种与算术运算相关的优雅，应用到其他类型的数据结构上。我们看到……我认为世界上的大部分地区都已经意识到这是一个
or they're updating the contents of some hash table, or, you know, everything is a very destructive mindset, typically. And when you're building your programs like that, your functions aren't pure functions. And there was something both intellectually unsatisfying about that to me. I mean, like, when you do two plus three, you're not destroying the number two and replacing it with five. So I kind of wanted that same, the same elegance that you associate with arithmetic operations, um, with, with other kinds of data structures. And we see that, uh, I think a lot of the world has caught on that this is a
有用的概念，你可以从字符串处理随时间的变化中看到证据。如果你回到 C 和 C++，字符串是可变的，对吧？在内存中原地更改字符串的任何字符都非常容易。事实证明，这可能是一场噩梦，因为很难跟踪是谁负责更改什么，你可能会意外地更改你不打算更改的字符串，因为你从字符串中提取了一些子字符串，
useful concept and you can see evidence for that in the way string handling has changed over time. If you go back to C and C++, strings are mutable, right? It's really easy to change any character of a string in place, in memory. And it turns out that can really be a nightmare because it's very hard to keep track of what's responsible for changing what things and you can accidentally change a string you didn't intend to because you extract some substring out of a string
而它实际上在内存中共享相同的空间，然后你更改了这个东西中的字符，结果却更改了另一个字符。这是一个问题。所以 Java 和 Python 以及我能想到的几乎每种现代语言，字符串默认都是不可变的。它让我们摆脱了……虽然有时效率较低，并且在性能确实需要时你需要某种方式降级到某种不可变数据结构。但通过在大多数语言中使字符串不可变，我们避免了巨大的头痛。我认为我发现，通过使你所有的对象、
and it's actually sharing the same space in memory and then you change the character in this one thing and it ends up changing this other character. It's a problem. And so Java and Python and a lot of, you know, almost every modern language I can think of, strings by default are immutable. And it frees us up from, I mean, there are times where that's less efficient, and you need some way to drop down to some kind of immutable data structure when it's really necessary for performance. But we have saved ourselves tremendous headaches by making strings now immutable in most languages. And I think I have found that you can get those same benefits by making all your objects,
所有的数据结构默认不可变，所有的集合，你也可以获得同样的好处。你知道，我有一个列表。当我向列表中添加东西时，我不应该破坏原始列表。我只是现在有了一个添加了一项的新列表。现在，围绕这个概念构建的语言允许你编写更纯的函数，因为你传入的是不可变的输入，并且得到的是纯输出。它使你的程序更容易分析。我发现这是一种更好的思考方式。这在当时发挥了作用，大约是我开始进行自己的益智游戏开发的时候。
all your data structures by default immutable, all your collections. You know, I have a list. When I add something to the list, I shouldn collections. I have a list. When I add something to the list, I shouldn't necessarily destroy the original list. I just now have a new list that is one item added on. Now, a language that's built around this concept then allows you to write more pure functions because you're passing in inputs that are immutable and you're getting pure outputs. It makes your program way easier to analyze. And I just find that to be a much better way of thinking about it. And it came into play, like at the time, this was around when I was starting to do my own puzzle development.
我相信我们以后会更多地谈论这个。但我分析的第一个谜题是 ThinkFun 出品的一款益智游戏，叫《Rush Hour》（塞车时刻）。《Rush Hour》是一款实体益智玩具，你有一个网格，并在网格上放置汽车，这些实体汽车。你有一张谜题卡，它会向你展示在网格上放置汽车的正确方式。然后你滑动这些汽车，试图让那辆红色的特殊汽车从出口出来。所以你们中的一些人可能作为实体益智玩具玩过它。也有很多不同的 iPhone 实现版本之类的。是的。
And I'm sure we'll be talking a lot more about that. But one of the first puzzles that I analyzed was a puzzle game by ThinkFun that's kind of a famous puzzle game called Rush Hour. And Rush Hour is a physical puzzle toy where you have a grid and you set up cars, these physical cars on the grid. You have a puzzle card that's kind of showing you the right way to set the cars up on the grid. And then you slide these cars around and you're trying to get the special red car out the exit. So some of you may have played that as a physical puzzle toy. There are also a lot of different iPhone implementations and things like that. Yep.
是的，对于没玩过的人来说，这个想法就是你有一堆交通堵塞的汽车。感觉就像……你想移动挡在你路上的那辆车，但你做不到，因为它被两边的另外两辆车挡住了。所以存在各种依赖关系。你必须通过移动棋盘另一边的汽车来解开所有这些，并利用这一点最终移动你想移动的汽车并让自己出去。为了分析这一点，我想构建一个图数据结构，对于给定的谜题，我想把滑动这些汽车所能进入的每一个可能的棋盘状态看作图数据结构中的一个节点。我想要边或箭头连接这个棋盘状态和通过一次滑动动作可以到达的所有其他合法棋盘状态。通过构建那个数据结构，我现在就拥有了一个
Yeah, just the idea for people who haven't played this is you have this sort of gridlock of cars. And it just feels like, you know, you want to move this one car that's in your way, but you can't because it's blocked, you know, on either side by these two other cars. And so there's all these sort of dependencies. And you have to sort of unravel all of that by moving cars all the way on the other side of the board, and kind of, you know, using that as leverage to eventually move the cars you do want to move and get yourself out. Now to analyze that, I wanted to build a graph data structure where for a given puzzle, I want to think of every possible board state that you can get into of sliding these cars around as kind of a node in a graph data structure. And I want edges or arrows kind of connecting this board state to all the other legal board states I can get to from this one with one sliding action. So by building up that data structure, I now have a
关于给定谜题中滑动这些汽车的所有可能方式的完整快照。好吧，在像 Python 这样的语言中……我第一次解决这个问题时，是在我使用 Python 的时代。构建图数据结构的一种自然方式是，正如我所说，我喜欢 Python 的一点是你不一定非要构建很多自定义数据结构，你可以直接使用内置的。所以一种自然的方式是 Python 中的内置数据结构——字典。
complete snapshot of every single way I can possibly slide these cars around for a given puzzle. Well, in something like Python, so the first time I tackled this, this was in the era when I was using Python. One natural way to do a graph data structure is, like I said, one of the things I like about Python is you don't necessarily have to build a lot of custom data structures, you can just use the built-in ones. So a natural way to do that is the built-in data structure of, in Python, a dictionary,
针对给定的谜题，我能以各种方式移动这些车辆的完整快照。在像Python这样的语言中，我第一次尝试解决这个问题时，正是我使用Python的时期。正如我所说，我喜欢Python的一点是，你不一定需要构建许多自定义数据结构，直接使用内置的即可。因此，实现图数据结构的一种自然方式就是使用Python内置的字典。
which in other languages is often called a hash table and you are your dictionary the keys are the state that you're in and the value it would be the list of all the states you can get to that that would be one way to model this graph data structure using a hash table. Well, Python has a restriction for good reason that the keys in your dictionary object have to be immutable. Well, that the most part, the built-in data structures in Python are not immutable. There are only a few things in Python that are immutable, numbers, strings, and tuples. But what I ended up doing was using strings to represent my states,
在其他语言中通常被称为哈希表，而在你的字典中，键是你所处的状态，值则是你可以到达的所有状态的列表，这就是使用哈希表来建模这种图数据结构的一种方法。嗯，Python 出于正当理由有一个限制，即字典对象中的键必须是不可变的。嗯，在很大程度上，Python 中的内置数据结构不是不可变的。Python 中只有少数几种不可变的东西：数字、字符串和元组。但我最终做的是使用字符串来表示我的状态，
my board states. So I had this kind of crazy flow to my program where I'd be representing a state as a string. I would unpack that string into some kind of mutable object so I could actually make moves on the board. And then when I got to the new states, I would convert them back to strings so that I could store all these things in the dict object. And I was thinking, this is kind of crazy. I mean, there's got to be a better way than this. And so, like I said, I was exploring lots of programming language. It's always kind of keeping tabs. And when I like I said, I was exploring lots of programming languages, always kind of keeping tabs. And when I saw Clojure, I just kind of fell in love with it right away because a lot of the older functional programming languages like Scheme, they really focus on one immutable data structure, usually the linked list. And there's only so far you can go with a linked list,
我的棋盘状态。所以我程序的流程有点疯狂，我把状态表示为一个字符串。我会把那个字符串解包成某种可变对象，这样我就能在棋盘上实际进行移动。然后当我到达新状态时，我会把它们转换回字符串，以便我可以把所有这些东西存储在字典对象中。我在想，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，一定有比这更好的方法。所以，就像我说的，我一直在探索很多编程语言。我总是会留意各种语言。就像我说的，我一直在探索很多编程语言，总是会留意各种语言。当我看到 Clojure 时，我立刻就爱上了它，因为很多较早的函数式编程语言（如 Scheme）确实只关注一种不可变数据结构，通常是链表。而链表能做的事情非常有限，
which is why I wasn't using Scheme for my own hobby project. But Clojure has a full suite of data structures, just like the ones built in a Python. You've got not only lists, but you've got things like arrays, you've got sets, you've got things like hash tables, and all of them are immutable. All of them can be used as keys and values and other hash tables are put in other collections, and you can nest these things however you want. And I found that rich tool set of immutable data structures, just this incredibly powerful toolkit for building up complicated representations of data and the functions that operate on them. So I really fell in love with that. And then once I started using Clojure, I found all these other benefits and then just never
这就是为什么我没有在自己的业余项目中使用 Scheme。但 Clojure 拥有一整套数据结构，就像 Python 内置的那样。你不仅有列表，还有数组、集合、哈希表，而且它们都是不可变的。它们都可以用作键和值，也可以放入其他哈希表或其他集合中，你可以随心所欲地嵌套这些东西。我发现那套丰富的不可变数据结构工具集，对于构建复杂的数据表示以及操作它们的功能来说，是一个极其强大的工具包。所以我真的爱上了它。一旦我开始使用 Clojure，我就发现了所有这些其他的好处，然后就再也没有
turned back. So Clojure, because it runs on the JVM, is way faster than Python. So I just got an enormous performance boost switching from Python to Clojure. Clojure has a real strong emphasis on concurrency. And a lot of the puzzle analysis work I do is very parallelizable, but Python didn't give me very great tools to do that with. And so suddenly with Clojure, I was able to write a program to solve puzzles and generate puzzles. And pretty trivially, I could spin that out to multiple processors. It has just a wonderful set of tools for working with concurrency. Yeah, Python has the global interpreter lock. Yeah, exactly.
回头了。所以 Clojure 因为运行在 JVM 上，比 Python 快得多。所以我从 Python 切换到 Clojure 后，性能得到了巨大的提升。Clojure 非常强调并发性。我所做的很多谜题分析工作都是高度可并行的，但 Python 没有给我提供很好的工具来做到这一点。所以突然之间，有了 Clojure，我就能编写程序来解决谜题和生成谜题了。而且非常简单地，我就可以将其分配到多个处理器上运行。它拥有一套非常棒的并发处理工具。是的，Python 有全局解释器锁。是的，没错。
Yeah, which for people who don't know, it's basically, you know, let's say in Python, you can have two threads. And the first thread could be trying to access a database. And so while it's, you know, using some low level C++ library to hit the database, your other thread could be doing something else useful. But if both threads are just doing Python code, let's say both threads just have a for loop and they're adding numbers, Python won't let both of them execute at the same time. So it'll actually let you go to the first thread and have that one add a number,
是的，对于那些不知道的人来说，这基本上就是，你知道，假设在 Python 中，你可以有两个线程。第一个线程可能正在尝试访问数据库。所以当它（你知道）使用一些底层的 C++ 库来访问数据库时，你的另一个线程可以做其他有用的事情。但如果两个线程都只是在执行 Python 代码，假设两个线程都只是有一个 for 循环并且它们在相加数字，Python 不会让它们同时执行。所以它实际上会让你转到第一个线程，让那个线程加一个数字，
and it'll go to the second thread, have that one add a number. And so no matter how many cores you have on your computer, it's only going to use one. But you can get around it no matter how many cores you have on your computer, it's only going to use one. But, you know, you can get around it using the multi-processing library in Python, but
然后它会转到第二个线程，让那个线程加一个数字。所以无论你的电脑有多少个核心，它都只会使用一个。但你可以绕过它，无论你的电脑有多少个核心，它都只会使用一个。但是，你知道，你可以使用 Python 中的多进程库来绕过它，但是
that's, it's almost like using Unix sockets. You really have to send things over the socket between the processes. It's very, very low level. But Java, you know, and all the JVM languages, they just are way better at the the processes is very very low level but uh but java you know and all the jvm languages they just are way better at at uh at the concurrency kind of routines yeah i mean that
那，那几乎就像在使用 Unix 套接字。你真的必须在进程之间通过套接字发送东西。这非常非常底层。但是 Java，你知道，以及所有的 JVM 语言，它们在并发例程方面要好得多，是的，我的意思是
that is exactly the kind of issues i i was having with python and uh the python gives you a little bit of that kind of interactive window to interact with your code, but Clojure kind of takes that to the next level also. In the Clojure community, they call it REPL-oriented development, where REPL stands for redevelop print loop. And they have a really rich set of tools for interacting with your code. And that turns out to be great for me when I'm doing my puzzle work. And I think most people when they're writing programs, they're sort of writing one program with a main function that's going to run and they're okay with compiling it and then running it. But what I was doing was building a set of tools for myself to use. And so my programs were more like a workbench of,
那正是我在 Python 中遇到的那种问题，而且 Python 确实为你提供了一点那种交互式窗口来与你的代码交互，但 Clojure 也把这一点提升到了一个新的水平。在 Clojure 社区中，他们称之为 REPL 驱动开发，其中 REPL 代表读取-求值-打印循环。他们有一套非常丰富的工具来与你的代码进行交互。事实证明，这对我做谜题工作非常有用。我认为大多数人在编写程序时，他们是在编写一个带有主函数的程序，该程序会运行，他们可以接受编译它然后运行它。但我所做的是为自己构建一套工具。所以我的程序更像是一个工作台，
you know, this can generate this kind of puzzle and this can solve this kind of use. And so my programs were more like a workbench of, you know, this can generate this kind of puzzle and this can solve this kind of puzzle. And I would write these things as independent functions and there was no real main function or something that I would run. I would just go into the REPL. I've built my whole workbench of tools and I would just type in commands to kind of like generate some puzzles and interact with them and try solving them and evaluating them and analyzing them and then make some tweaks to the puzzle and then solve it again and make sure it still has a unique solution. And I could do all this interactively from my Ruppel window, just fluidly interacting with all the code that I had written. So I just love that feeling of, you know, I'm building myself a workbench with all these great tools. And it's just a wonderful workflow.
你知道，这个可以生成这种谜题，那个可以解决这种谜题。我会把这些东西写成独立的函数，没有真正的主函数或我需要运行的东西。我只会进入 REPL。我已经构建了我的整个工具工作台，我只需要输入命令来生成一些谜题，与它们交互，尝试解决它们，评估它们，分析它们，然后对谜题做一些调整，然后再解决它，确保它仍然有一个唯一的解。我可以在我的 REPL 窗口中交互式地完成所有这些，流畅地与我编写的所有代码进行交互。所以我真的很喜欢那种感觉，你知道，我正在为自己构建一个拥有所有这些伟大工具的工作台。这真是一个美妙的工作流程。
And finally, a couple of years in a Clojure, they came out with Clojure Script, which is a version of Clojure that compiles to JavaScript. And for me, that was a huge benefit because I've always found the semantics of JavaScript just a little clunky and awkward. And for me, being able to apply these concepts that to me make Clojure so natural and so wonderful to web programming and to building graphical programs and websites and HTML games, you know, all these things I can do from ClojureScript. And it's easy to use the same logic that I've written and tested for building and solving my puzzles. In the JVM version of Clojure,
最后，在使用 Clojure 几年后，他们推出了 ClojureScript，这是 Clojure 的一个版本，可以编译成 JavaScript。对我来说，这是一个巨大的好处，因为我一直觉得 JavaScript 的语义有点笨拙和尴尬。对我来说，能够将这些让我觉得 Clojure 如此自然和美妙的概念应用到 Web 编程、构建图形程序、网站和 HTML 游戏上，你知道，所有这些我都可以通过 ClojureScript 来完成。而且很容易使用我为构建和解决谜题而编写和测试的相同逻辑。在 JVM 版本的 Clojure 中，
a lot of it can just be ported right over the ClojureScript version, and I can get the same behavior right there in the browser. Yeah, in episode 61, we had Eric Normand on the show who runs a website called Purely Functional where he teaches Clojure and ClojureScript. And he actually mentioned you can now even use ClojureScript
很多代码可以直接移植到 ClojureScript 版本，我可以在浏览器中获得相同的行为。是的，在第 61 期节目中，我们邀请了 Eric Normand，他经营着一个名为 Purely Functional 的网站，他在那里教授 Clojure 和 ClojureScript。他实际上提到你现在甚至可以使用 ClojureScript
to write for mobile. So you could actually take your games and assuming you have to redo the UI, but you can actually use the same language and target mobile. Yeah, I think a lot of the people who are doing mobile are using tools that are built on top of Facebook's React native toolkit.
来编写移动端应用。所以你实际上可以拿走你的游戏，假设你必须重做 UI，但你实际上可以使用相同的语言并针对移动平台。是的，我认为很多做移动端的人正在使用构建在 Facebook 的 React Native 工具包之上的工具。
So it actually is a lot. I think a lot of the same UI code that you've written for the web, if you're using that toolkit, does translate over directly to the mobile platform too, because that's how React Native works. But yeah, I know Eric and he's a great Clojure trainer and he's probably done more than anyone else to put out a lot of high quality videos and training materials especially for people who are interested in using closure to build websites that's one that she's done a lot to provide great materials on cool so yeah uh yeah one question so so solving the puzzles, you know, that seems, let's say, intuitive, right? I mean, it could be difficult mp complete you know type search where you know
所以它实际上确实有很多。我认为如果你使用那个工具包，你为 Web 编写的很多相同的 UI 代码确实可以直接转换到移动平台，因为 React Native 就是这样工作的。但是是的，我认识 Eric，他是一位出色的 Clojure 培训师，他可能比任何人都做得更多，发布了大量高质量的视频和培训材料，特别是对于那些有兴趣使用 Clojure 构建网站的人来说，这是他做了很多工作来提供优质材料的一个领域。酷，所以是的，嗯，是的，一个问题，所以，解决谜题，你知道，这看起来，怎么说呢，直观，对吧？我的意思是，它可能是一个困难的 NP 完全问题类型的搜索，你知道，
hopefully you use some heuristics or maybe there's some tricks like it decomposes but it always ends up involving some type of you know kind of search or planning um how does the generation work you know like like how do you go about generating it just because you could write a Sudoku solver? It doesn't necessarily mean that you could make a Sudoku level. And it definitely doesn't mean you could make a level targeted to a particular audience. Like if you want to make a Sudoku level for children or if you want to make a Sudoku level for, you know, experts. Like how do you go about parameterizing that and actually you know you've made three board games which we'll talk about and and that's the part that I find fascinating is how do you actually
希望你使用一些启发式方法，或者也许有一些技巧，比如它会分解，但它总是涉及到某种类型的搜索或规划。嗯，生成过程是如何工作的？你知道，就像你是如何去生成它的？仅仅因为你能写一个数独求解器，并不一定意味着你能制作一个数独关卡。而且这绝对不意味着你能制作一个针对特定受众的关卡。比如如果你想为孩子们制作一个数独关卡，或者如果你想为专家制作一个数独关卡。你是如何去参数化它的？而且实际上，你知道，你已经制作了三款棋盘游戏，我们将讨论这些，这就是我发现最迷人的部分，你是如何实际
create the levels and how do you sort of guarantee that that they're sort of playable and usable right yeah I mean that's that's the heart of what I do so yeah I'm happy to explain it although I'll tell you in advance that it's kind of like when a magician shows you how the trick is done, you go, oh, is that all there is? I'm sure that'll happen here. I'll explain to you how it is and it'll no longer seem mystifying. You go, really? Is that all there is to that? So I kind of view the process as three steps for most puzzle games. It kind of breaks down the three steps. The first step, like you said, is to write the solver. And I think that's the piece that most people can get their head around. Like you said, most problems boil down to some kind of search. I would recommend to your listeners out there who are just learning computer science,
创建关卡，以及你如何保证它们是可玩和可用的？是的，我的意思是，这是我工作的核心，所以是的，我很乐意解释它，尽管我会提前告诉你，这有点像魔术师向你展示戏法是如何完成的，你会说，哦，就这吗？我相信这里也会发生同样的情况。我会向你解释它是如何工作的，它将不再显得神秘。你会说，真的吗？就这吗？所以我把大多数益智游戏的过程看作三个步骤。它大致分为三个步骤。第一步，就像你说的，是编写求解器。我认为这是大多数人都能理解的部分。就像你说的，大多数问题归结为某种搜索。我会向那些刚开始学习计算机科学的听众推荐，
learn how to write an A-star search. That's a famous algorithm for searching. And it is, I would say 99% of what I do boils down to some flavor of an A-star search. So that is, and surprisingly, I mean, a lot of people don't know how to write that and that's fine, but it's actually not that hard. So learn it and it's an incredibly powerful tool. There are also other tools that allow you, as you said, a lot of puzzles boil down to NP complete problems. And we actually have a lot of tools out there for solving NP-complete problems as long as they're not ridiculously hard and take forever to run, right? And fortunately, most puzzle games, for a human to be able to solve
学习如何编写 A* 搜索。这是一种著名的搜索算法。而且，我可以说是 99% 的工作都归结为某种形式的 A* 搜索。所以这就是，而且令人惊讶的是，我的意思是，很多人不知道如何编写它，这没关系，但它实际上并不难。所以去学习它，它是一个极其强大的工具。还有其他工具可以让你，正如你所说，很多谜题归结为 NP 完全问题。我们实际上有很多工具可以用来解决 NP 完全问题，只要它们不是难到离谱且运行时间无限长，对吧？幸运的是，大多数益智游戏，对于人类来说能够解决
them, are usually relatively small problem sizes relative to what a computer can solve. So even when these things are NP-complete, usually they're quite tractable on a computer. And you can apply some of these tools and for example there are constraint solving engines there are boolean satisfiability problem engines i actually gave a talk about this at the last closure conference people can find it online if they want either the talk i gave was called solving problems declaratively and i took that to the show yeah i took i took a sample classic puzzle and i walked through how you would solve that with a few different kind of declarative problem solving tools that let you just kind of model you don't even have to worry about how to express the
它们，通常相对于计算机能解决的问题来说，问题规模相对较小。所以即使这些问题是 NP 完全的，通常它们在计算机上也是非常易于处理的。你可以应用其中一些工具，例如有约束求解引擎，有布尔可满足性问题引擎。我实际上在上次 Clojure 大会上做过关于这个的演讲，如果人们想看的话可以在网上找到。我做的那个演讲叫“声明式解决问题”，我把它带到了节目中。是的，我拿了一个经典的谜题样本，并演示了如何用几种不同的声明式问题解决工具来解决它，这些工具让你只需要建模，你甚至不必担心如何表达
solving process these tools are so robust that in a lot of cases you can just model the problem write down a model of how the problem works and then pass it into this solver and it'll just solve it for you nice yeah i just just to sort of expound on that a bit a lot of people don't know this but basically so so a star is a type of what's called a fixed beam search and what that means is uh you know a fixed beam search is where um imagine you know you have some tree and and you know at the bottom of this tree are a bunch of leaves and each leaf has has some score but you have some intuition as to what the score is going to be as you're going down in the tree. So if you're thinking about, say, a game tree, you know if you're losing. If it's a monopoly and everyone around you has hotels and you don't,
求解过程。这些工具非常强大，在很多情况下，你只需要对问题进行建模，写下问题如何工作的模型，然后将其传递给求解器，它就会为你解决它。不错。是的，我只是想对此进行一点阐述，很多人不知道这一点，但基本上，所以 A* 是一种所谓的固定束搜索，这意味着什么呢？嗯，你知道，固定束搜索是，嗯，想象一下，你知道你有一棵树，并且你知道在这棵树的底部有一堆叶子，每个叶子都有一些分数，但当你沿着树向下走时，你对分数会是多少有一些直觉。所以如果你在考虑，比如，一棵游戏树，你知道如果你正在输。如果这是一场大富翁游戏，你周围的每个人都有酒店而你没有，
you know you're in trouble. But you might pull it off and win the whole game, but you have some intuition. And so what beam search does, fixed beam search, is it will try to use its intuition to sort of go down the best path that it thinks about the moment and when it finds the answer then it goes back up the tree and it says well let me check some more answers near the one i found to see if there's an even better one and sort of depending on how you construct it, you can get an approximate
你知道你遇到了麻烦。但你可能会成功并赢得整个游戏，但你有一些直觉。所以束搜索，固定束搜索所做的是，它会尝试利用它的直觉沿着它当下认为的最佳路径走下去，当它找到答案时，它会回到树上，它会说，好吧，让我检查一下我找到的那个答案附近的一些其他答案，看看是否有更好的一个。并且根据你的构建方式，你可以得到一个近似
solution or you can get an exact solution. In other words, you can say, look, these things here, because I know some bounds on them, I don't have to explore that part of the tree anymore. You know, I know that all the leaves in this part of the tree are going to be between one and 10 and already have an 11 over there. So I know I could just drop this part of the tree are going to be between one and 10 and already have an 11 over there so i know i could just drop that part of the tree um and that's that's basically how like the entire tech industry works right if you're on amazon.com and and amazon suggests items to you they have three billion or maybe 30 billion things that they're selling, and they can show you 10, and they could do it every time you hit refresh.
解，或者你可以得到一个精确解。换句话说，你可以说，看，这些东西在这里，因为我知道它们的一些界限，我不需要再探索树的那部分了。你知道，我知道这部分树中的所有叶子都在 1 到 10 之间，而那边已经有一个 11 了。所以我知道我可以放弃这部分树，因为我知道这部分树中的所有叶子都在 1 到 10 之间，而那边已经有一个 11 了，所以我知道我可以放弃那部分树。嗯，这基本上就是整个科技行业运作的方式，对吧？如果你在 Amazon.com 上，亚马逊向你推荐商品，他们有 30 亿甚至 300 亿件商品在售，
The reason why they can do that is because they're doing a fixed beam search. So they basically, they have what's called an embedding or a latent space or a projection. They have a projection of you, and they have a projection of all their inventory and they try to line those up but they don't line them up one at a time they use this tree and so the same with like google the search engine you know facebook the ordering of the things in the feed twitter like the whole internet runs on effectively fixed beam search, which ASTAR is a member of. And so, yeah, ASTAR is something absolutely everybody should learn and code up. And there's an awesome Wikipedia page on ASTAR, which kind of has the code.
而他们可以向你展示 10 件，并且他们可以在你每次刷新时都这样做。他们之所以能做到这一点，是因为他们正在进行固定束搜索。所以他们基本上，他们拥有所谓的嵌入或潜在空间或投影。他们有你的投影，他们有他们所有库存的投影，他们试图将它们对齐，但他们不是一次对齐一个，他们使用这棵树。所以对于像谷歌这样的搜索引擎，你知道，Facebook 动态消息中事物的排序，Twitter，整个互联网实际上都在运行固定束搜索，A* 就是其中的一员。所以，是的，A* 是绝对每个人都应该学习和编写代码的东西。维基百科上有一个很棒的关于 A* 的页面，它有代码。
Literally, you could copy-paste it and also kind of graphically shows you what it's doing. And I might be able to make that a little more concrete even by talking about that in the context of that Rush Hour game that we were talking about. In Rush Hour, you've got the tangle of cars and you're trying to get that special red car out of the exit. And if you're going to search for a solution, you ideally want to search the moves that are going to be more likely to lead you to a solution, things that are get your red car closer to the exit. So the key there and the key part of any A-star search is to come up with a lower bound on how many moves it's going to take you from this state to the solution. So a simple lower bound for rush hour is, you know, how many spaces do I have to slide this red car over and how many things are in its way? Because each thing that in its way
字面上，你可以复制粘贴它，而且它还以图形方式向你展示了它在做什么。我或许可以通过在我们要讨论的那个“尖峰时刻”游戏的背景下谈论它，让它变得更具体一点。在“尖峰时刻”中，你有一堆纠缠在一起的汽车，你正试图让那辆特殊的红色汽车从出口出来。如果你要搜索解决方案，你理想情况下想要搜索那些更有可能引导你找到解决方案的移动，那些让你的红色汽车更接近出口的移动。所以那里的关键，以及任何 A* 搜索的关键部分，是得出一个关于从当前状态到解决方案需要多少步的下界。所以“尖峰时刻”的一个简单下界是，你知道，我必须把这辆红色汽车滑过多少个空格，以及有多少东西挡在它的路上？因为挡在它路上的每一样东西
is a minimum of one move to get that car out of the way. So you can look at a position and say, okay, this is going to take a minimum of seven moves to get the red car out. Maybe a lot more than that, but I know it's going to take at least seven. So I'm going to look for moves that move me towards something where the lower bound is six. Like I've basically moved the red car a little bit closer to the exit, or I've gotten one of those cars out of the way. Anything that helps reduce that lower bound is more likely to lead me to a solution. So that's kind of the heart, in my mind, of what A-star search is all about.
至少需要移动一步才能把那辆车移开。所以你可以观察一个位置并说，好吧，这至少需要 7 步才能把红色汽车移出来。也许比这多得多，但我知道至少需要 7 步。所以我将寻找那些让我朝着下界为 6 的方向移动的移动。就像我基本上把红色汽车向出口移动了一点，或者我把其中一辆挡路的汽车移开了。任何有助于降低那个下界的东西都更有可能引导我找到解决方案。所以在我看来，这就是 A* 搜索的核心所在。
So you've written the solver. Yeah. So now you have to generate the levels. How do you go about doing that? Okay, well, the simplest way to do it is to randomly generate a ton of puzzles and then find the good ones.
所以你已经写好了求解器。是的。那么现在你必须生成关卡。你是怎么做到的？好吧，最简单的方法是随机生成大量的谜题，然后找出好的那些。
This is where I said the revealing the trick. And you need to have a fast solver to do that, which is why having a good fast solver is always the first step. But at this point, like, you know, let's take Rush Hour again, for example, since we've already described how that game works.
这就是我所说的揭示戏法的地方。你需要有一个快速的求解器来做到这一点，这就是为什么拥有一个好的快速求解器始终是第一步。但在这一点上，就像，你知道，让我们再次以“尖峰时刻”为例，因为我们已经描述了那个游戏是如何工作的。
You can kind of set up a random car configuration by kind of working backwards, like placing cars one at a time onto the board. So you put the red car down, and this is the thing I'm going to try to slide out the exit, and then I stick a car in front of it to block it. And then I stick a car in front of that car, you know, the car that's going to need to be slid out of the way. I put something to block that and I put a few more cars down. And now I have this random configuration of cars and I solve it. And maybe it's not solvable,
你可以通过倒推的方式设置一个随机的汽车配置，比如一次在棋盘上放置一辆车。所以你放下红色汽车，这就是我试图滑出出口的那辆车，然后我在它前面放一辆车来挡住它。然后我在那辆车前面放一辆车，你知道，那辆需要被滑开的汽车。我放了一些东西来挡住它，我又放了几辆车。现在我有了这个随机的汽车配置，然后我解开它。也许它是不可解的，
in which case I just throw it away but if it is solvable now I have a puzzle and so I can create a database of you know 20 30 000 puzzles and now the key becomes to analyze those and to figure out which ones are good and that that is actually the that that turns out most people think it's the generation that's the hard part, but it's actually the figuring out the good ones that is the hard part. Early on when I was doing this Rush Hour work, at the time, well, first, as a little bit of background context, ThinkFun, the company that makes Rush Hour, their tradition has always been to come out with puzzles where you have this beautiful handcrafted collection of 40 puzzle cards that come with the game when you buy
在这种情况下，我就把它扔掉。但如果它是可解的，现在我有一个谜题了。所以我可以创建一个包含 20,000 到 30,000 个谜题的数据库，现在关键在于分析这些谜题并找出哪些是好的。而这实际上是，事实证明，大多数人认为生成是困难的部分，但实际上找出好的谜题才是困难的部分。早些时候，当我做“尖峰时刻”这项工作时，当时，嗯，首先，作为一点背景信息，ThinkFun，制作“尖峰时刻”的公司，他们的传统一直是推出那些你购买游戏时附带的精美手工制作的 40 张谜题卡集合
it. And they're just clever and well designed. And they're just, it's a beautiful sequence of 40 puzzles. Well, when the iPhone came out, you know, there were kind of knockoff versions that were, that would put in a bunch of random puzzles, a lot more than 40 puzzles, and maybe they're not so good and not, but you got a lot more puzzles. And so that becomes attractive to people. And so ThinkFun came to me and said, we want to learn how to make these rush hour puzzles on kind of a large scale so that we can also have our own app with hundreds of puzzles but we want our quality to be better than these competitors we want these puzzles to rival the handcrafted quality of the original set that's how we want to you know surpass these knockoffs and i thought that was a wonderful challenge. And that's why I got excited
。它们既聪明又设计精良。而且它们只是一个由 40 个谜题组成的精美序列。嗯，当 iPhone 出来时，你知道，有一些山寨版本，它们会放入一堆随机的谜题，远不止 40 个谜题，也许它们不是那么好，但你得到了更多的谜题。所以这对人们来说变得很有吸引力。于是 ThinkFun 来找我说，我们想学习如何大规模地制作这些“尖峰时刻”谜题，这样我们也可以拥有自己的应用程序，里面有数百个谜题，但我们希望我们的质量比这些竞争对手更好，我们希望这些谜题能媲美原始套装的手工质量，这就是我们想要超越这些山寨货的方式。我觉得这是一个很棒的挑战。这就是我感到兴奋的原因
about the project. And that was, you know, one of the first major projects I did, puzzle research projects I did for ThinkFun. You're sort of tapping into your cognitive psychology background again. Yeah. But when I studied cognitive science at Rice, I thought a lot about, a big part of what I did in the cognitive science program was look at how people solved puzzles because that's what had always fascinated me um and so what i realized like i said is the generation is the easy part now the hard part is how do i figure out which of these are good like a lot of these you know random generators, they would use some very naive measure to figure out how hard a puzzle is, like how long is the solution. I mean, that seems like
关于这个项目。那是，你知道，我为 ThinkFun 做的第一个主要项目，谜题研究项目。你又在利用你的认知心理学背景了。是的。但在莱斯大学学习认知科学时，我思考了很多，我在认知科学项目中做的一大部分工作是研究人们是如何解决谜题的，因为那一直让我着迷。所以正如我所说，我意识到生成是容易的部分，现在困难的部分是我如何找出哪些是好的。很多这些，你知道，随机生成器，它们会使用一些非常天真的衡量标准来计算谜题有多难，比如解决方案有多长。我的意思是，这看起来像
a reasonable measure, but it turns out to not be the best measure. So players would kind of play through the puzzle sequence, this randomly generated puzzle sequence of another product, and something that was labeled as easy would actually be a hard puzzle or something that was a hard puzzle labeled would actually turn out to be easy. And that's frustrating for the players. So how do we calibrate the difficult? How do we figure out exactly what the difficulty of these puzzles are? How do we make sure they're good quality puzzles? That's where the challenge lies. And what i found is that the key is to kind of throw away the solver you've built for this third phase even though it's it's fundamentally a solving problem
一个合理的衡量标准，但事实证明它不是最好的衡量标准。所以玩家会玩过这个谜题序列，这个来自另一个产品的随机生成的谜题序列，被标记为简单的东西实际上可能是一个困难的谜题，或者被标记为困难的东西实际上结果却很简单。这对玩家来说很令人沮丧。那么我们如何校准难度呢？我们如何准确地找出这些谜题的难度？我们如何确保它们是高质量的谜题？这就是挑战所在。我发现关键在于为这个第三阶段抛弃你构建的求解器，即使它从根本上是一个求解问题
what i want to know now is how would a human solve this puzzle that's the question so you know that's going to be maybe a slower process to emulate than like these speedy off the shelf solvers that can just crank through a model of a problem and generate a solution fast. And you need that fast solver to do the random generation process and quickly screen for solvable and unsolvable puzzles. You want to write a more deeper model, a more complex program that models how you think humans would solve it. And you also want to do a lot of measurements on the puzzle space, the state space. Not just how many moves there are, but how many different states you can get into. What does the shape of that state space look like? How many dead ends are there? Like you kind of want to map out what the puzzle looks like.
我现在想知道的是，人类将如何解决这个谜题？这就是问题所在。所以你知道，这可能是一个比那些现成的快速求解器更慢的过程，那些求解器可以快速通过问题模型并快速生成解决方案。你需要那个快速求解器来进行随机生成过程，并快速筛选出可解和不可解的谜题。你想要编写一个更深层的模型，一个更复杂的程序，模拟你认为人类会如何解决它。而且你还想对谜题空间、状态空间进行大量的测量。不仅仅是有多少步，还有你可以进入多少种不同的状态。那个状态空间的形状是什么样的？有多少死胡同？你有点想把谜题的样子绘制出来。
And so, and then you want to synthesize all those measures and your model of maybe even one or more models of how humans might solve this. And you have all these measurements and you want to come up with some kind of way to combine those measurements into an overall rating. And that's kind of the same problem that like machine learning is used for right now. You've got all these different numerical attributes and you're trying to use it to predict some overall numerical attribute of a system.
所以，然后你想综合所有这些衡量标准以及你对人类可能如何解决这个问题的模型，甚至是一个或多个模型。你拥有所有这些测量数据，并且你想出某种方法将这些测量数据组合成一个整体评分。这有点像现在机器学习所使用的问题。你拥有所有这些不同的数值属性，并且你正试图用它来预测系统的某个整体数值属性。
Yeah, I was about to say it sounds a lot like uh like policy gradient so so policy gradient is this idea where um you know instead of saying whether something is good or bad you you um you basically have an expert so this case would be you the designer or some other human play the game and you'd have a system that learns what that person would do so in other words given a game that the the algorithm hasn't seen before it will try to make the same moves that the human being would have made whether those moves are good or not and this is actually how they bootstrap like the world champion go player and things like that they they boot because the state space is so large for Go, they bootstrap it with policy gradient.
是的，我正要说这听起来很像策略梯度。所以策略梯度是这样一个想法，嗯，你知道，与其说某事是好是坏，你基本上有一个专家，在这种情况下就是你，设计师，或者其他人类玩游戏，并且你有一个系统可以学习那个人会做什么。换句话说，给定一个算法以前没见过的游戏，它会尝试做出人类会做出的相同动作，无论这些动作是好是坏。这实际上就是他们如何引导像世界冠军围棋选手之类的人工智能，因为围棋的状态空间太大了，他们用策略梯度来引导它。
So they basically say, look, there's all these expert human players. They all have these things in common. Maybe they're the best. Maybe they're not. Maybe there's a better way. But the state space is so big, we're just going to start by, you know, doing policy gradient and putting our algorithm in this niche where it's, you know, emulating all these expert players.
所以他们基本上说，看，有这么多专家级人类玩家。他们都有这些共同点。也许他们是最好的。也许不是。也许有更好的方法。但状态空间太大了，我们只是要从，你知道，做策略梯度开始，把我们的算法放在这个利基市场中，在那里它正在模拟所有这些专家玩家。
And then we'll start to do some planning after that. Yeah, I mean, that's exactly right. Now, what would be nice is if I had tons of people playing through these puzzles and rating them, and then I could literally pass it through a machine learning algorithm to figure out how to map all these measures I've created to the overall rating. But in practice, we don't do that. What it really comes down to is I use my own knowledge of puzzles and puzzle solving. I play through the puzzles, a lot of random sample puzzles, and kind of compare my own ratings of puzzles and puzzle solving. I play through the puzzles, a lot of random sample puzzles, and kind of compare my own ratings of the puzzles to what is being produced by these
然后我们会在那之后开始做一些规划。是的，我的意思是，那完全正确。现在，如果我有成千上万的人玩这些谜题并给它们评分，那会很好，然后我可以字面上通过机器学习算法来找出如何将我创建的所有这些衡量标准映射到整体评分。但在实践中，我们不这样做。真正归结为我使用自己对谜题和谜题解决的知识。我玩过这些谜题，很多随机样本谜题，并比较我自己对谜题的评分，我玩过这些谜题，很多随机样本谜题，并比较我自己对谜题的评分与这些
different measures. And I kind of find a way to, I kind of keep tweaking the formula of how I'm going to combine these, kind of the way a machine learning program might do it, but I just kind of do it manually and with my own sampling process until I come up with a formula that hopefully does a pretty good job of measuring the interestingness and the difficulty of these puzzles. What does the formula do? So the formula takes into account like the graph, like the state space and that adjacency graph like like what's the formula based on so some of the measures might be the number of moves in a solution uh it might be how uh it depends on the game rush hour doesn't exactly have dead ends but you can imagine like you can get into state spaces that are maybe further away from a goal than where you started. And so understanding, like, the average distance of
不同的衡量标准所产生的结果。我找到了一种方法，我不断调整我将如何组合这些的公式，有点像机器学习程序可能会做的那样，但我只是手动进行，并结合我自己的采样过程，直到我想出一个公式，希望它在衡量这些谜题的趣味性和难度方面做得相当不错。这个公式做了什么？所以这个公式考虑了像图，像状态空间和那个邻接图，像公式是基于什么的？所以一些衡量标准可能是解决方案中的步数，它可能是如何，这取决于游戏，“尖峰时刻”并不完全有死胡同，但你可以想象，你可以进入可能比你开始的地方离目标更远的状态空间。所以理解，比如，平均距离
a given state to the solution, like, so I can come up with, you know, 10 different measures that seem like they might work. But the heart of it, the key is, again, the most useful measure is going to be how long is it going to take a human player to solve it? And so here's an example of the kind of thing I might do. I've tried a lot of different heuristics with rush hour, for example, to kind of get a feeling for what feels like the, what, what is producing something that maps well to real level difficulty. And one of the things I found was that if you imagine a really naive player, one of the ways they might play is they might kind of make random moves for a while.
一个给定状态到解决方案的距离，所以我可以想出 10 个看起来可能有效的不同衡量标准。但它的核心，关键是，再次，最有用的衡量标准将是人类玩家解决它需要多长时间？所以这是一个我可能会做的事情的例子。例如，我在“尖峰时刻”上尝试了很多不同的启发式方法，以感受一下什么感觉是，什么正在产生与真实关卡难度相符的东西。我发现的一件事是，如果你想象一个非常天真的玩家，他们玩游戏的一种方式可能是他们会进行随机移动。
And if they get about three or four moves away from the solution, they can see that. And then they go make a beeline for the solution. And they might be a little more intelligent about it in terms of not just making purely random moves, but at least making moves that don't undo what they just did. Like that would be something that most people wouldn't do is just immediately undo the move they do for no reason. So you can program in maybe a preference for making moves that are novel, that take you to some kind of new state space. And so I would code up this kind of logic and then I would run it. And it has a certain amount of randomness to it.
如果他们离解决方案大约三四步远，他们就能看到这一点。然后他们就会直奔解决方案。而且他们在不只是进行纯粹的随机移动方面可能会更聪明一些，至少会做出不会撤销他们刚刚所做的事情的移动。就像大多数人不会做的那样，就是为了什么理由都没有而立即撤销他们所做的移动。所以你可以编程加入一种对做出新颖移动的偏好，这些移动会带你进入某种新的状态空间。所以我编写了这种逻辑，然后我运行它。它有一定的随机性。
But I would so I would run it multiple times and see like this, this virtual player. How many moves does it take this virtual player to solve this puzzle and running that and taking an average of a bunch of times it turns out to be a really really useful measure and then combining it with those other statistics i can get a really good handle on the difficulty level of a puzzle cool that's amazing i mean i just want something i always wondered and uh and uh yeah you totally you totally cracked uh but actually you know i uh i'm going to challenge you on that a little bit i think it actually was was really super insightful like i i was expecting when you prep when you prefaced it
但我会，所以我多次运行它，看看这个虚拟玩家。这个虚拟玩家解决这个谜题需要多少步，运行它并取多次的平均值，结果证明是一个非常非常有用的衡量标准，然后将其与那些其他统计数据结合起来，我可以很好地掌握谜题的难度级别。酷，这太棒了。我的意思是，我只是想要一些我一直想知道的东西，而且，是的，你完全破解了，但实际上，你知道，我，我要在这方面挑战你一点，我认为它实际上确实非常深刻，就像我，我期待着当你准备时，当你为它做序时
i was expecting it to be uh you know we just count count distance from the goal and then i was actually in my head i was kind of thinking, well, you know, there might be some that are very deceptive and things like that. But yeah, I mean, this idea of sort of you model the human and then you try to refine that model by observing how it plays. Like, that's really cool.
我期待着它是，你知道，我们只是计算距离目标的距离，然后我实际上在脑子里想，好吧，你知道，可能有一些非常具有欺骗性的东西等等。但是是的，我的意思是，这种模拟人类的想法，然后你尝试通过观察它如何玩来改进那个模型。这真的很酷。
And that's, so you put all of that to the test when you made these new three games that are coming out this month. That's right. Very cool. So, yeah, we should we should dive into them. So why don't you tell everyone about the three games you made? So so Patrick and I, super lucky we got early copies and we played them with with our families and uh we had a ton of fun with them um but yeah why don't you why don't you kind of explain to everyone uh you know what they're in for this month well a few years ago think fun approached me and because they know that i'm a programming guy and i i do puzzles and i approach puzzles with a programming mindset. And I also work as an educator in the programming field, teaching other homeschool students in the area. science activities, games and puzzles that would teach kids who play them computer science
这就是，所以当你制作这三款本月即将推出的新游戏时，你把所有这些都付诸实践了。没错。非常酷。所以，是的，我们应该深入了解它们。所以为什么不告诉大家你制作的三款游戏呢？所以 Patrick 和我，超级幸运，我们得到了早期副本，我们和我们的家人一起玩了它们，我们玩得很开心，但是是的，为什么你不向大家解释一下，你知道，他们这个月会遇到什么？好吧，几年前 ThinkFun 找到我，因为他们知道我是一个编程人员，我做谜题，我用编程思维来处理谜题。而且我也作为教育工作者在编程领域工作，教当地的其他在家上学的学生。科学活动、游戏和谜题，这些可以教玩它们的孩子计算机科学
principles just by playing these puzzle games and having fun. And they shared this vision with me and asked me to create products that accomplished that. And the first product I did for that was a game for ThinkFun called Codemaster. And Codemaster came out a couple years ago. And Codemaster started out as a Target exclusive for the first year. And it was a big success. And people really enjoyed it and really liked it. And Target wanted more and this was a good thing. So they came back to me and said can you develop a line of three new games that, you know, explore different kinds of computer science principles, each one doing something a little different so that the three kind of go together and help build a picture of, you know, what it's like to think as a computer scientist that kids can do this. As a teacher, I was really inspired by this project because as a teacher, and I think
原则，仅仅通过玩这些益智游戏并获得乐趣。他们与我分享了这个愿景，并要求我创建实现这一目标的各种产品。我为此做的第一个产品是为 ThinkFun 制作的一款名为 Codemaster 的游戏。Codemaster 是几年前推出的。Codemaster 第一年开始时是 Target 的独家产品。它非常成功。人们真的很喜欢它，真的很喜欢它。Target 想要更多，这是一件好事。所以他们回来找我说，你能开发一系列三款新游戏吗，你知道，探索不同种类的计算机科学原则，每一款都做一些不同的事情，这样这三款游戏可以结合在一起，帮助建立一幅图景，你知道，像计算机科学家一样思考是什么感觉，孩子们可以做到这一点。作为一名教师，我真的被这个项目所激励，因为作为一名教师，我认为
all computer science teachers find this, there are some kids in the class that just immediately seem to get it when you teach programming. They're like, yes, it's intuitive. They just get it from the outset. And there are others that really struggle. And so the question teachers always ask each other when they get together at conferences and things like that is, why is it that, you know, some kids struggle and some kids just get it right off the bat? Is it something innate? Is it something that can be taught? You know, what's going on here?
所有的计算机科学老师都会发现这一点，班上有些孩子在教编程时似乎立刻就明白了。他们就像，是的，这很直观。他们从一开始就明白了。而另一些人则真的很挣扎。所以老师们在会议等场合聚在一起时总是互相问的问题是，为什么，你知道，有些孩子挣扎，而有些孩子立刻就明白了？这是天生的吗？这是可以教的吗？你知道，这里发生了什么？
And I, after having a lot of these discussions and doing a lot of research, it's become pretty clear to me that it is teachable. And you want to teach that as early as possible. Because what you want, like my hope with these puzzle games, and I'll go into the details of what each one does and what each principle, each one illustrates. But they don't literally teach programming in the sense like you're not going to play the puzzle games and sit down at the computer and start programming and see. That's not the goal. The goal is that you get kids playing these games and they're going to get a good mental model of how computers interpret and execute programs. They're going to get a good mental model of how logical statements are evaluated. You know, all these things, they're going to gain the mental frameworks that when they get
在进行了很多这些讨论并做了很多研究之后，对我来说已经很清楚了，它是可以教授的。而且你想尽可能早地教授它。因为你想要的，就像我对这些益智游戏的希望一样，我会详细说明每一个做什么以及每一个说明什么原则。但它们并不是字面上教授编程，就像你不会玩这些益智游戏然后坐在电脑前开始编程一样。这不是目标。目标是让孩子们玩这些游戏，他们会获得关于计算机如何解释和执行程序的良好心理模型。他们会获得关于逻辑语句如何评估的良好心理模型。你知道，所有这些东西，他们将获得心理框架，当他们得到
into a classroom later, these kids are going to be the ones that just get it. And that's my dream, is that like a generation of kids play these games. And then, you know, 10 years from now, teachers are saying, what's going on all these kids are showing up in my class and they're all finding programming really easy you know that that's my dream that's what i want and that makes sense i mean we both i don't know about pat i'll let patrick go second but but we we uh we both played a bunch of games growing up i used to i used to play this game called delta drawing which uh was just turtle turtle graphics if you've ever done this which is like uh how do you describe it like uh um like an
以后走进教室，这些孩子会是那些一点就通的人。这就是我的梦想，让一代孩子玩这些游戏。然后，你知道，10年后，老师们会说，怎么回事，这些孩子来到我的班上，他们都觉得编程很容易，你知道，这就是我的梦想，这就是我想要的。这很有道理，我的意思是，我们俩——我不知道帕特怎么想，我会让帕特里克第二个说——但我们俩小时候都玩过很多游戏。我以前常玩一个叫“海龟绘图”（Delta Drawing）的游戏，那其实就是海龟绘图，如果你玩过的话，就像是……你怎么描述它呢，就像是一个……
off-centric uh drawing tool so you have this little arrow and you say you know go forward three spaces then draw for three spaces and turn left and then draw and so you have to kind of understand that when the arrow turns left even though you didn't move it kind of like you have to sort of project yourself onto the arrow and write some simple code and it had a bunch of instructions of how to draw a square how to draw you know uh you know a hexagon and things like that and uh that i felt like things like that are really what sort of give people the right mindset when they're young. Yeah, definitely.
非中心化的绘图工具，你有一个小箭头，你说，你知道，向前走三格，然后画三格，向左转，然后再画。所以你必须理解，当箭头向左转时，即使你没有移动，你也必须把自己投射到箭头上去，写一些简单的代码。它有一堆指令，教你怎么画正方形、六边形之类的东西。我觉得像这样的东西，确实能在孩子们年轻时赋予他们正确的思维方式。是的，绝对是这样。
And so I started. So let me talk about the three games specifically. So the first game in the series is called On the Brink. And I would say that this is the one that's maybe the most accessible to the youngest kids. All the games are rated as ages eight and up, but this one is maybe skews a little bit easier. The basically you were talking about turtle graphics just now. And for many years, the basic computer game model and the model for getting kids working with programming was turtle graphics. The idea of a robot character, a turtle robot character that you can give it movements like move forward, turn left, turn right, and you're moving around a board or you're drawing some kind
所以我开始了。让我具体谈谈这三款游戏。系列中的第一款游戏叫《On the Brink》。我会说这是对最小的孩子来说最容易上手的一款。所有的游戏都标为8岁及以上，但这一款可能稍微简单一点。你刚才基本上是在谈论海龟绘图。多年来，基础电脑游戏模型以及让孩子们接触编程的模型就是海龟绘图。一个机器人角色的概念，一个你可以给它下达指令（如向前移动、向左转、向右转）的海龟机器人，你在棋盘上移动它，或者用它画出某种
of shape with it. And these are very, very common activities to do with kids. And what I wanted to do was accomplish two things with On the Brink. I wanted to take kids and show them this, you know, turtle graphics paradigm, but I wanted to give them some actual concrete puzzles they could solve. Because my experience is that kids get really motivated by solving puzzles in a way that they might not if you just give them an open-ended activity. You know, make this turtle move around any way you want is a little different than figure out how to solve this puzzle. And for certain kind of kids, they get really excited about this puzzle solving process. And it'll, you know, to get better at something in life,
形状。这些是与孩子们一起进行的非常非常常见的活动。我想通过《On the Brink》实现两件事。我想带孩子们了解这种海龟绘图范式，但我还想给他们一些可以解决的具体谜题。因为我的经验是，孩子们在解决谜题时会非常有动力，这与你只给他们一个开放式的活动是不同的。你知道，让海龟随心所欲地移动，和弄清楚如何解决这个谜题是两码事。对于某些孩子来说，他们会对这种解谜过程感到非常兴奋。而且，你知道，要在生活中变得更好，
you need to constantly challenge yourself to kind of work at the threshold of what you're comfortable. And most people don't like that feeling innately of kind of stretching themselves, but puzzles that naturally build in sequence kind of do that automatically for kids. Once they get hooked on the game and get hooked on the puzzle, each one is a little bit harder than the one before, and they're stretching themselves without realizing it. And by the end, they've accomplished all this so i wanted to to do something that was built out of turtle graphics instructions forward turn left turn right and you know make a puzzle out of it so that was that was the basic concept but the skill that i wanted to tackle with this was the idea of procedural abstraction um the idea of procedural abstraction.
你需要不断挑战自己，在舒适区的边缘工作。大多数人天生不喜欢那种强迫自己进步的感觉，但自然构建成序列的谜题会自动为孩子们做到这一点。一旦他们迷上了游戏，迷上了谜题，每一个都比前一个稍微难一点，他们在不知不觉中就提升了自己。到最后，他们完成了所有这些，所以我想要做一些基于海龟绘图指令（向前、向左转、向右转）的东西，并把它做成一个谜题。这就是基本概念，但我想要通过这个解决的技能是“过程抽象”的概念，嗯，过程抽象的概念。
The idea, like to me, one of the most beautiful things about computer science and the one thing, like even if someone doesn't go into computer science as a profession, the one thing I hope they walk away with with exposure to computer science is the idea that computer science is all about building components out of smaller components and then taking these new components we built and reusing those and building bigger things out of that.
对我来说，计算机科学中最美妙的事情之一，也是即使某人将来不从事计算机科学职业，我也希望他们能从接触计算机科学中带走的东西，就是计算机科学的核心在于用更小的组件构建组件，然后利用我们构建的这些新组件进行重用，并在此基础上构建更大的东西。
Like that's what allows us to build the amazing programs we do as software engineers is everything's kind of built on top of another level. And that's what I wanted to give kids a taste of. So what I did is I set it up. The idea behind On the Brink is you've got a board that's a bunch of colored spaces and you've got a robot. And the way it works is it kind of looks at what color it's standing on. It could be red or blue or green. And if it's standing on red, it goes and executes the red procedure. And then wherever it, let's say it's standing on red, it executes the red procedure. it's standing and then wherever it let's say it's standing on red it executes the red procedure and then wherever it lands it looks at that color space and if it's now on blue it's going to go execute the blue procedure and so on and the puzzle is this the player is given these cards, these instruction cards, forward, turn left, turn right, and they're trying to assemble the procedures, and we keep it really simple so it's accessible
这就是让我们作为软件工程师能够构建出惊人程序的原因，一切都是建立在另一层之上的。这就是我想让孩子们体验的东西。所以我做了这样的设置。《On the Brink》背后的想法是，你有一个由彩色方块组成的棋盘，还有一个机器人。它的工作方式是观察它所站立的颜色。可能是红色、蓝色或绿色。如果它站在红色上，它就会去执行红色过程。然后无论它……假设它站在红色上，它执行红色过程。它站在那里，然后无论它……假设它站在红色上，它执行红色过程，然后无论它落在哪里，它都会观察那个颜色空间，如果现在是蓝色，它就会去执行蓝色过程，以此类推。谜题是这样的：玩家会得到这些卡片，这些指令卡片（向前、向左转、向右转），他们试图组装这些过程，我们保持它非常简单，以便它对
to younger kids and they can do this, you know, in a reasonable way. They're just worrying about two-step procedures. But what they're having to think about is that level of abstraction. You know, there's a bunch of red spaces on the board and whatever procedure they write, it has to work at all the red locations on the board. It's got to make sense everywhere. So you're figuring out how to make this reusable piece. And then as they get to later levels, we kick it up a notch.
年龄较小的孩子来说是可访问的，他们可以以合理的方式做到这一点。他们只需要担心两步过程。但他们必须思考的是那种抽象水平。你知道，棋盘上有一堆红色方块，无论他们编写什么过程，它都必须在棋盘上所有的红色位置上起作用。它必须在任何地方都讲得通。所以你是在弄清楚如何制作这个可重用的部分。然后当他们进入后面的关卡时，我们会提高难度。
And instead of giving them the instruction cards that are just forward, left, and right, we give them a new set of cards where each card is a procedure built out of forward, left and right. So, for example, there's I think there's an instruction there called like long turn right, which is a combination of forward, turn right and move forward again. So it kind of moves the robot in kind of a bigger arc than just turning in place. And so you have these bigger instructions and now they're building procedures out of procedures. So again, they're seeing firsthand through play that you can, you know, reuse components to build other components. So we give them things that feel familiar from their first, you know, built out of the forward left and right, they're building the procedures out
我们不再给他们只有向前、向左和向右的指令卡，而是给他们一套新的卡片，每张卡片都是由向前、向左和向右构建的过程。例如，我想那里有一个指令叫“长右转”，它是向前、向右转和再次向前移动的组合。所以它让机器人以比原地转弯更大的弧度移动。所以你有这些更大的指令，现在他们正在用过程构建过程。所以同样，他们通过游戏亲眼看到，你可以重用组件来构建其他组件。所以我们给他们一些从第一次（由向前、向左和向右构建）中感到熟悉的东西，他们现在正在用那些过程构建过程。
of those procedures now. And then by the, for most of the puzzles, we kind of tell them which cards they're going to need to use. But the last expert level, we don't even tell them what cards they need to use. So now it's getting a little more freeform. It's starting to feel a little bit more like the real programming process. But all along the way, they've gotten a taste of what it's like to abstract a problem out to bigger and bigger levels of abstraction, composing pieces into bigger pieces, and trying to find something that can be reusable across many different sites.
然后对于大多数谜题，我们都会告诉他们需要使用哪些卡片。但最后一个专家级关卡，我们甚至不告诉他们需要使用什么卡片。所以现在它变得更加自由了。它开始感觉更像真正的编程过程。但一路走来，他们已经尝到了将问题抽象到越来越高的抽象层次、将碎片组合成更大的碎片，并试图找到可以在许多不同位置重用的东西的滋味。
So I actually played through this one, my wife and I did. So I went through all the levels and mostly just sort of let my wife try, who's not a computer programmer. And the thing that I really liked is by the end, realizing that you may be on a certain color square, but that isn't sufficient to tell you what's going to happen. You actually have to know how you got there. And that's a pretty high level concept that matters a lot. That the state of your program when you get into a function matters, especially if you don't write in a functional programming language
所以我实际上玩通了这一关，我和我妻子一起。所以我玩了所有关卡，大部分时间只是让我妻子尝试，她不是计算机程序员。我真正喜欢的一点是，到最后意识到，你可能站在某个颜色的方块上，但这不足以告诉你接下来会发生什么。你实际上必须知道你是怎么到那里的。这是一个非常高水平的概念，非常重要。当你进入一个函数时，程序的当前状态很重要，特别是如果你不是用函数式编程语言编写的话，
can matter on a lot of other things right so that leaving aside that but i mean that's sort of a very abstract concept that if i sort of enter a red square from the left what's going to happen is different than if i enter a red square from the top um and which way i'm facing and so uh you know that is a very abstract concept that i thought was introduced very nicely that it was like, oh, OK, now I need to know I may be revisiting the same square multiple times. Or maybe I'm spoiling stuff, but I need to revisit the same square multiple times. Coming at it from different directions. Yeah. And that was sort of like, oh, uh-huh. Like, now I get it.
在很多其他事情上也很重要，对吧？所以撇开这一点不谈，我的意思是，这是一个非常抽象的概念，如果我从左边进入一个红色方块，发生的事情与我从顶部进入一个红色方块是不同的，嗯，还有我面向哪个方向，所以你知道，这是一个非常抽象的概念，我认为它被引入得非常好，就像是，哦，好的，现在我需要知道我可能会多次访问同一个方块。或者我可能在剧透，但我需要多次访问同一个方块。从不同的方向接近它。是的。那就像是，哦，啊哈。就像，现在我明白了。
So I thought it was really nice. And also the fact that you can, and I don't know that it's considered cheating, but you can sort of work backwards. If you know where you need to get, you can sort of figure out what moves are valid to get you there. And then that sort of, you can work from both ends. And then that also often simplifies your problem. Yeah, and I don't consider that cheating at all.
所以我认为这真的很好。还有一点，我不知道这是否被认为是作弊，但你可以倒着推。如果你知道你需要到达哪里，你可以弄清楚哪些移动是有效的，可以让你到达那里。然后，你可以从两端开始工作。这通常也会简化你的问题。是的，我根本不认为那是作弊。
I think that's an essential thing that I want kids to hopefully discover as they play this, is that, yeah, working backwards or maybe there's some, maybe the front and backwards are kind of unclear. The front end and the back end might be unclear, but there's something in the middle that is kind of clear for whatever reason. And so you focus on whatever part is tractable and then figure out how to tackle the other pieces from there once that's constrained. So yeah, that's a big part of what I hope players will learn and experience while playing through this. Yeah, so like you said, I can imagine, you know, someone playing this game isn't going to come away debugging a broken C program.
我认为这是我希望孩子们在玩这个游戏时能够发现的一个基本点，那就是，是的，倒着工作，或者也许前面和后面有点不清楚。前端和后端可能不清楚，但中间有什么东西因为某种原因很清楚。所以你专注于任何可处理的部分，一旦受到约束，就弄清楚如何从那里处理其他部分。所以是的，这是我希望玩家在玩这个游戏时能学到和体验到的很大一部分。是的，就像你说的，我可以想象，你知道，玩这个游戏的人不会在调试一个损坏的C程序。
But, you know, if you're introducing them to a concept, they're going to recall, oh, my brain knows how to do this. I've seen this before. This function, I write this function, and then I can put it in different places and get it to do different things, even though it's the same function.
但是，你知道，如果你向他们介绍一个概念，他们会回忆起，哦，我的大脑知道怎么做这个。我以前见过这个。这个函数，我写了这个函数，然后我可以把它放在不同的地方，让它做不同的事情，即使它是同一个函数。
Yeah, it's about laying that foundation, setting up that mindset of how programmers and computer scientists approach things. It's kind of like martial arts. They teach you self-defense and these things, and you make it sort of innate. And if you're in some terrible situation, you're probably not going to exactly do the right form and do a figure eight in cartwheels or something but you have to have that instinct to sort of use the leverage
是的，这是关于打下基础，建立程序员和计算机科学家处理事情的思维方式。这有点像武术。他们教你自卫和这些东西，你让它变得天生。如果你处于某种可怕的情况，你可能不会完全做出正确的动作，做个侧手翻什么的，但你必须有那种本能去利用
you need to use to escape that situation and it's the same kind of thing where you're not going to sit your eight year old down and say hey I want you to write this C program but what you can do is you can play this game with them
你需要利用的杠杆来逃离那种情况，这和那种情况是一样的，你不会让你的八岁孩子坐下来，说嘿，我想让你写这个C程序，但你可以做的是，你可以和他们一起玩这个游戏，
and give them the instincts so that when they invariably end up in coding 101 in 11th grade or whenever, that they have this huge advantage and it feels natural. Yeah, that is exactly what I'm aiming for. So thank you. I'm glad that came across. Cool. Yeah, I actually played the,
给他们本能，这样当他们不可避免地在11年级或任何时候进入编程101课程时，他们就有这个巨大的优势，而且感觉很自然。是的，这正是我的目标。所以谢谢。我很高兴这一点被传达出来了。酷。是的，我实际上玩了，
I didn't play this one that you just described yet, but I played the Rover Control game. Yeah, so you want me to talk a little bit? Yeah, absolutely. I'll talk a little more about Rover Control. So Rover Control is where I feel this is kind of the second game of the series. And here we're starting to get into what I think is the really core skill that separates the kids who kind of get it from those who don't. And this is the key skill that I want kids to learn.
我还没玩过你刚才描述的那个，但我玩了《Rover Control》游戏。是的，你想让我多谈谈吗？是的，当然。我会多谈谈《Rover Control》。所以《Rover Control》是我觉得这是该系列的第二款游戏。在这里，我们开始进入我认为真正区分那些“懂了”的孩子和那些“没懂”的孩子的核心技能。这是我希望孩子们学习的关键技能。
And that is the ability to mentally step through code. For those of us who are in the programming profession, maybe that seems so obvious that we don't even think about that as a skill that one needs to acquire. But my understanding of the research from having read up on this a lot and looking at different investigations into this is that the key thing that separates the kids who get it from those who don't is the kids who get it have this kind of ability to role play the computer in their mind and and step through the the steps of their program mentally And if you can't do that, then, I mean, if you can't predict how your program is going to be interpreted, how can you possibly write a program? You have to understand how this thing is going to be evaluated. And where it gets especially tricky and what
那就是在脑海中逐步执行代码的能力。对于我们这些从事编程职业的人来说，这似乎太明显了，以至于我们甚至不认为这是一种需要习得的技能。但我从阅读大量相关资料和查看对此的不同调查中得出的理解是，区分懂了的孩子和没懂的孩子的关键在于，懂了的孩子有一种在脑海中扮演计算机并逐步执行程序步骤的能力。如果你做不到这一点，那么，我的意思是，如果你不能预测你的程序将如何被解释，你怎么可能写出一个程序？你必须了解这个东西将如何被评估。而它变得特别棘手的地方，以及
Rover Control focuses on is things like while loops, if then else branches. When I would go to these teacher conferences, one thing I'd hear over and over again is, oh my God, while loops are so hard to teach. And when I was a new teacher, I would think, why are while loops hard to teach that I don't see what's so hard about that? Well, it turns out there are certain common conceptions that kids have when
《Rover Control》关注的是像while循环、if-then-else分支这样的东西。当我参加这些教师会议时，我听到的一件事是，哦天哪，while循环太难教了。当我还是个新老师时，我会想，为什么while循环难教？我看不出有什么难的？好吧，事实证明，孩子们在学习编程时有一些常见的概念，当你看到while循环时，常见的误解是，如果控制while循环的条件在循环体中间被违反或变为假，学生们认为它会像魔法一样在条件变为假时立即跳出循环。这是学生对while循环的头号误解之一，当我听到这个时，是的，我有同样的反应，哇，是的，现在我明白为什么孩子们看不懂了，是的，这确实是一个合理的想法，只是计算机不是那样工作的，但认为它们可能那样工作是完全合理的。所以现在我要去写一种那样做的语言，只是为了捉弄人。
they're learning programming when you see the with while loops the common misconception is that if the condition that governs the while loop is violated in them or becomes false in the middle of the body of the loop students think that it just kind of magically jumps out of a loop as soon as the condition becomes false this is this is like one of the number one misconceptions that students have about while loops and i when i heard that yeah i had kind of that same reaction whoa yeah now i see why kids aren't seeing it yeah like that is a reasonable thing to think would happen it's just not the way computers work but it it's totally reasonable to think that they might work that way so now i'm going to go write a language that does that right just to mess with people
是的，完全正确，所以我不会那样做。所以《Rover Control》展示了程序的这一点。想法是你有一个在火星景观上的循线机器人。你的工作是，有一个程序向机器人解释，跟随红线，然后跟随绿线。检查你是否在特定的位置。如果是，做这件事。否则，做另一件事。这个程序写出来了，但为了让孩子们容易理解，它是以图形格式编写的。我从
yeah exactly so i'm. I won't do that. So Rover Control shows programs for this. The idea is you have this line-following robot on a Martian landscape. And your job is, there's this program that explains to the robot, follow the red line, then follow the green line. Check if you're at this particular location. If you are, do this one thing. Otherwise, do this other thing. This program is written out, but to make it accessible to kids, it's written in a graphical format. Kind of a visual flowchart kind of system that I came up with drawing from
一堆不同的灵感来源中汲取灵感，设计出的一种视觉流程图系统。但它是程序的视觉表示。想法是你试图给地图上的线条上色，使这个程序真正起作用，做它应该做的事情，也就是让机器人从这个位置移动到另一个位置。对于一些谜题，有类似调试打印语句的东西，打印出机器人在程序中某些点应该在的位置。你必须确保程序也与此匹配。所以这里的想法是，它正在锻炼的技能是他们正在学习，比如假设你有一个程序。其中一个谜题可能基于while循环的视觉表示。
a bunch of different inspirational sources. But it's a visual representation of the program. And the idea is you're trying to color the lines of the map to make this program actually work, to do what it's supposed to do, which is to get the robot from this location to this other location. And for some of the puzzles, there's the equivalent of like debug print line statements that print out where the robot's supposed to be at certain points in the program. And you got to make sure the program matches that as well. So the idea here that the skills that this is exercising is they're learning, like let's say you have a program. One of the puzzles might be based around a visual representation of a while loop.
他们正在使用图形系统以流程图的方式逐步执行它。他们看到只有在循环体执行完毕并回到条件判断时，才会重新评估while条件。他们通过尝试绘制不同的地图和绘制彩色线条来学习。他们正在使用逻辑。就像如果我们只是制作一个游戏，练习“这是一个程序，弄清楚机器人最终在哪里”，那并不有趣，对吧？孩子们不会做那种感觉像练习的事情，但想法是你给他们一些有趣的事情来做，比如“这是这个程序，弄清楚如何给地图上色”，即使一旦你
And they're stepping through this in kind of a flowchart way using the graphical system. And they're seeing that you only reevaluate that while condition after you're done with the body of the loop and you kind of come back to the condition. And they're learning as they try drawing different maps and drawing the colored lines. They're using logic. Like if we just made a game that was an exercise of here's a program, figure out where the robot ends up. Like that's not interesting right kids aren't going to do something that feels like an exercise but the idea is you give them something interesting to do with that here's this program figure out how to color the map and even once you
能理解，即使你是一个优秀的程序员，你可以完美地阅读这个程序并理解它是如何工作的，仍然有一个谜题需要解决，你仍然必须弄清楚给线条上色的正确方法，而且这里有一点技巧，因为机器人可能会在程序中的某一点重叠在自己的路径上，你必须确保它以正确的方式上色，你知道，可能会发生不同种类的技巧，所以这就是核心，他们正在练习在脑海中逐步执行这段代码，并且他们正在学习计算机实际评估这些程序的方式。现在，当老师在未来的编程课上向学生展示while循环时，
can understand even if you're a good programmer and you can read this program flawlessly and understand how this works there's still a puzzle to be solved and you still have to figure out the right way to color the lines and there's a little bit of trickiness there because the the robot might overlap on its own path at a certain point in the program and you got to make sure it's colored the right way for you know there's different kinds of tricks that might happen um so that's the heart of it, though, is that they're practicing stepping through this code mentally, and they're learning the way computers actually evaluate these sorts of programs. And now when a teacher shows a student a while loop in their future programming
它将变得非常有意义。他们将成为那些直观地认为只有回到顶部时才评估条件的人之一，因为他们已经看到了那个模型，并且习惯于以那种方式逐步执行代码，而且对他们来说，这就是计算机处理程序的方式，这看起来完全自然，因为他们在玩《Rover Control》时，已经练习过在脑海中扮演计算机的角色，同时解释和执行这些程序。是的，这完全说得通。我一直在为老师们开发，我一直在开发所有《Rover Control》谜题的版本，这些谜题是用实际代码编写的，而不是图形语言。我实际上在GitHub仓库上放了一些，
class, it's going to make perfect sense. They're going to be one of the ones that it's intuitively obvious that you only evaluate the condition when it comes back to the top because they've seen that model and they're used to stepping through code in that way and it's going to seem completely natural to them that that's how computers process programs because they had already practiced being the role of the computer mentally while they interpreted and executed these programs while playing Rover Control. Yeah, that totally makes sense. I've been developing for teachers to use. I've been developing a version of all the Rover Control puzzles that are written in actual code rather than the graphical language. And I actually have some of that up on a GitHub repository
我可以给你链接。但你可以通过查看每个程序的JavaScript版本来玩同样的谜题。同样，有一个谜题需要解决。如果你在玩的时候不明白如何解释while循环，你翻过页面，现在你有图形版本。你可以来回切换。哦，这是图形版本。这是书面版本。
that I can give you the link towards. But you can play through the same puzzles looking at, you know, the JavaScript version, for example, of each of these programs. And again, there's a puzzle to be solved. And if you're playing through it and you don't understand how to interpret the while loop, you flip the page over and now you got the graphical version. You can kind of go back and forth between the two. Oh, this is the graphical version. This is the written version.
我现在明白了如何解释这个。所以它确实可以作为一个强大的教育工具。但即使他们不在常规代码和图形代码之间来回切换，仅仅通过玩这个图形版本，他们也会建立起计算机如何解释程序的心理模型，以及他们如何能够自己逐步执行事情。是的，当我和我儿子玩的时候，我儿子四岁，所以我们没玩到while循环，但我们玩了第一关，为了给人们一个心理模型，某种画面，基本上你有这些不同的颜色。当你追踪这条路径和这些颜色时，迷宫上有一些点，我们
I understand now how to interpret this. So it can really be used as a powerful educational device. But even if they're not going back and forth between the regular code and the graphical code, just by playing this graphical version, they are going to build that mental model of how to how computers interpret programs how they can mentally step through things on their own yeah the uh when i played it with my my son my son's four so so he's it's you know we didn't get to while loops but uh um you know we played the first level where um just to give people sort of like a mental model, sort of picture of this, basically you have these different colors. And as you sort of trace this path and these colors, there's some spots on the maze, we'll
称之为，在你开始之前就已经涂上了某种颜色。所以，例如，如果你的颜色是红色、蓝色、红色，可能有一条路径可以让你到达目标，但那条路径的第一段是蓝色。由于你的程序的第一段必须是红色，你不能走那条路径。所以你做的第一件事是填满所有预先规定的部分，然后我儿子看到，哦，我不能走这条直接通往目标的路径，因为上面有一个蓝色的，我必须放一个红色的，所以他在别的地方放了一个红色的，然后几次尝试后，
call it, that are already colored in with a certain color before you even started. So, for example, you know, if your colors are sort of, let's say, red, blue, red, you know, there might be a path that gets you to the goal, but that path, you know, the first link in that path was blue. And since your first link, you know, from the program has to be red you can't take that path so so uh the first thing you do is you kind of fill in all the parts that are you know dictated in advance and then my son saw oh you know i can't take this path that goes straight to the goal because there's a blue one on there and i have to put a red one and so he put a red one somewhere else uh and then you know after a couple of tries
他弄清楚了，哦，如果我放一个红色的，那么我就必须跟随蓝色的，这意味着我必须走这边，那边，然后去目标。所以第一个非常容易上手，你几乎不可能搞砸。然后它给你提供了越来越难、越来越复杂的垫脚石。但很酷的是，正如马克之前提到的，你有这些垫脚石。所以有一种“我懂了”的时刻，
he kind of figured out that that oh you know if i put a red one then i have to follow the the blue one and so that means i have to go this way that way and then and then go to the goal so the first one was was was super accessible like you really like uh you almost can't really mess it up. And then it gives you kind of stepping stones to harder and harder, more complex problems. But the cool thing is, as Mark alluded to earlier, you have these stepping stones. And so there's sort of this I got it moment
几乎任何人都能得到。这将给他们动力去投入时间和精力进入下一个关卡，然后再下一个。你们俩遇到过我提到的那个游戏《Codemaster》吗？我几年前做的那个？不，我正在看图片。我不认为我以前玩过它。
that almost anyone can get. And that will give them the momentum to invest that time and energy to go to the next level and then the next level. Have either of you encountered the game I mentioned, Codemaster, the one I did a couple of years ago? No, I was looking at the picture. I don't actually think I've played it before.
所以《Codemaster》和《Rover Control》在某种意义上是配套的谜题。你几乎可以把《Rover Control》看作是《Codemaster》的续集，但它们可以以任何顺序玩，因为它们都使用相同的视觉语言来描述程序。它们都是关于在脑海中逐步执行代码，理解流程控制结构。区别在于在《Codemaster》中，地图已经涂好了颜色，你有在流程图上移动的编程令牌。在《Rover Control》中，指令已经填好了，你在给地图上色。所以它们是
So Codemaster and Rover Control are in a sense, companion puzzles. You can almost think of Rover Control as like the sequel to Codemaster, but they can be played in any order because they both use the same visual language to describe programs. And they're both kind of about the same thing of mentally stepping through code, understanding flow control constructs. The difference is that in Codemaster, the maps are already colored in and you've got programming tokens that you're shuffling around on the flow chart. In Rover Control, the instructions are already filled in and you're coloring in the map. So they're like inverse directions
你试图完成的目标的相反方向，但使用相同的基本系统。酷，这说得通。那么，帕特里克，你玩了第三个吗？哦，我没有。哦，请继续。我想到还有一件事我想提一下关于《Rover Control》，那就是因为我正在做
of what you're trying to accomplish but using the same basic system. Cool, that makes sense. And so, I don't know, Patrick, did you play the third one? Oh, I didn't. Oh, go ahead. I thought of one more thing I wanted to mention about Rover Control, which is that because I was doing it
这个游戏的另一个方向，你看着程序并构建地图，我能够做一些更复杂的程序。就像在《Codemaster》中，我不得不限制自己使用12种基本程序形状。而在《Rover Control》中，几乎每个程序都是不同的。我确实利用那个机会提高了难度。例如，当你进入高级谜题时，我们已经讨论了if-then-else和while循环。但在高级水平，我引入了非常类似于for循环的东西。当你进入专家级谜题时，实际上有两个不同的
in kind of the other direction for this one, and you're looking at the programs and building the map, I was able to do some more complicated kinds of programs. And like in Codemaster, I had to kind of restrict myself to 12 basic program shapes. Whereas in Rover Control, almost every program is different. And I really took that opportunity to kind of kick it up a different. And I really took that opportunity to kind of kick it up a notch. And for example, when you get to the advanced puzzles, we already talked about if, then else, and while loop. But at the advanced level, I introduced something very similar to for loops. And when you get to the expert puzzles, there's actually two different
机器人在这个地图上跑来跑去。你必须以这样一种方式绘制地图，即同一个程序对两个从地图上不同位置开始的机器人都能起作用。所以一旦你达到专家水平，它就变得非常棘手。我会说这是我看了最后一个谜题的那一个。我是一个坏人。我打开它们，直接去了最难的谜题。在所有三个中，这是当我翻到最难的谜题时，我想“哦，那行不通”的那一个。另外两个，我会说我确实设法直接去了最难的谜题，并且弄清楚了，但我认为这些不是为成年程序员设计的，所以那不是操场上的所有孩子都会被吓倒，你会是那个拿走每个人午餐钱的人，那是一个批评。那根本不是对游戏的批评。这只是一个陈述。是的，我相信从我能看出的情况来看，这一个可能包含最多的复杂性。是的，我只是说当你去孩子们玩这个游戏的中学时，
robots running around this map. And you have to draw the map in such a way that the same program will work for both robots starting in different locations on the map. So it gets pretty tricky once you get to the expert level. I will say this is the one I looked at the last puzzle. I was a bad person. I opened them up and immediately went to the hardest puzzle. And of all the three, this was the one when i flipped to the hardest puzzle i was like oh that's not gonna work uh the other two i will say i did i actually managed to just go straight
你会是那种“阿尔法学生”。你可以回到你的母校中学，孩子们在玩这个游戏，你会是那种“阿尔法学生”。你可以回到你的母校中学。所以我是一个非常尴尬的人，只是碰巧很聪明。我不想回到中学。中学太糟糕了。中学太糟糕了。哦，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。没有侧面技巧。那是真的。是的，那可能需要整整一个小时来解释。
to the hardest puzzle and you know figure it out but you know i these aren't i don't think these are designed for adult programmers uh so that that's not all the kids in the schoolyard would be intimidated you'd be the one taking everyone's lunch money that's a critique. That's not a critique of the games at all. It's just a statement that I will say. Yeah, I believe this one probably has the most intricacies associated with it, from what I could tell. Yeah, I was just saying that when you go to the middle school where the kids are playing this game,
但中学似乎永远都很糟糕。其实，快速岔开话题。他们实际上说，当你有了蹒跚学步的孩子，比如“可怕的两岁”，你的孩子会因为他们的发脾气而愤怒。这是因为他们的大脑中释放了某种化学物质。那种化学物质正在淹没他们的大脑。这就是导致所有这些愤怒的原因。好吧，你实际上在中学时也释放了同样的化学物质。
you will be sort of the alpha student. You can go back to your alma mater middle school where the kids are playing this game, you will be sort of the alpha student. You can go back to your alma mater middle school. So I'm a very awkward and just happen to be smart. I don't want to go back to middle school. Middle school was terrible. Middle school was terrible. Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. No side tricks. That's true. Yeah, that would probably take a whole hour to explain.
我的意思是，我不是编出来的。那是真的。可能当你调试程序时也是这样。是的，那是真的。我想我从来没有放弃过，显然。所以，是的，不幸的是，我没能玩到第三个游戏，但请解释一下，因为我很期待。好的，所以第三个游戏……计算机科学老师的另一个热门话题是，学生们很难理解逻辑表达式、逻辑连接词（如“与”、“或”、“非”），然后当你进入更复杂的东西（如“异或”）时，它变得更加
But middle school just seems to be terrible forever. Actually, so, okay, quick side track. They actually say the, you know, like when you have toddlers, like the terrible twos, that the, you know, your kid can kind of rage at their tantrums. That's because they're releasing a certain chemical in their brain. And that chemical is just flooding their brain. And that's what's're releasing a certain chemical in their brain, and that chemical is just flooding their brain, and that's what's causing all this rage. Well, you actually released the same chemical in middle school.
复杂，但……就像我……部分原因是大多数计算机科学课程在课程顺序中没有留出太多时间来学习这个。所以发生的情况是，老师们讲到教逻辑的部分。你需要知道它，因为它会出现在你所有的if语句条件中。你需要知道如何做这些事情。他们只是说，好的，这是“与”，这是“或”，这是“非”。他们期望学生利用他们的直觉，也许是从英语语言中，你知道，只是他们在英语中的经验来指导这些东西在编程中是如何评估的。
I mean, I'm not just making that up. That's true. And probably when you're debugging programs. Yeah, that's true. I don't think I ever gave it up, apparently. So, yeah, unfortunately, I didn't get to the third game uh but but yeah please explain it because i'm looking forward to it okay so the third game uh came about another another hot button issue for computer science teachers is that the students it's very hard to communicate to them a deep understanding of logical expressions logical connectives like and and or and not and then when you get to more complicated things like x or you know that it gets even more
然后他们就从那里继续前进了。问题在于，“或”是一个经典的例子，“或”在数学和编程中与在日常对话中不太一样。大多数人并不认为“或”是包含性的“或”，即如果两件事都为真。如果我在教孩子们逻辑时对某人说，我会举个例子，比如“今晚我要去吃晚饭，或者我要去看电影”。现在，如果你后来发现我吃了晚饭，而且我也看了电影，我在撒谎吗？很多人会说，“是的，你在撒谎。你说你要么去吃晚饭，要么去看电影，但你两样都做了。所以你在撒谎。”我说，“不，在数学和计算机科学中，如果你做了‘或’的两件事，那仍然是好的。”
complicated but um like i was and part of that is simply because most curricula for computer science just don't allow a whole lot of time in the curriculum sequence for that. So what happens is teachers get to the part where they're teaching logic. And you need to know it because it's going to show up in all your if statements as the condition. And you're going to need to know how to do this stuff. And they just kind of say, okay, here's and, here's or, here's not. And they kind of expect students to use their intuition, maybe from the English language, you know, just their experience with it in English to guide how these things are evaluated in programming.
什么？你知道，我的意思是，这是基本的，不仅是计算机科学，而且是所有数学的工作方式，数学证明，科学语言。我的意思是，任何时候你在精确的上下文中使用“或”，除非另有说明，否则都假定为包含性的“或”。所以我们真的把孩子们带偏了。然后一旦你加入一个“非”，我的意思是，当孩子们试图处理双重否定时，他们需要一段时间才能理解。但一旦你开始说一些话，比如，嗯，作为一个经典例子，在编程中，你可能想说，你知道，X在1到5之间。那么我该怎么做呢？我可能会说，你知道，1小于或等于X，且X小于或等于5。那么我怎么对它取“非”呢？嗯，我可能会……显而易见的方法是我可以在整个“与”表达式周围加上一个“非”，但很多孩子会弄错，他们会做类似“非X大于等于1且非X小于5”的事情，这正是你不想做的。如果你对各个部分取“非”，你需要把“与”改成“或”。那是德·摩根定律。这些东西对于孩子们来说，仅仅通过英语语言思考是不会自然产生的。你需要学习如何评估它，如何推理它，而那种事情需要练习。所以我从这个前提开始：
And they just kind of move on from there the problem with that is that like or is a classic example or is not quite the same in math and programming as it is in everyday conversation most people do not think of or as the inclusive or where if both things are true like if i said to somebody when i'm teaching logic to kids i'll give the example something like um tonight i am going to dinner or i am going to the movies now if you later find out that i ate dinner and i went to the movies was i lying and a lot of them yeah you were lying you said you're going to either go to the dinner or go to the movies and you did both. So you're lying. And I'm like, no, in math and computer science, if you do both things of an or, it's still good.
我想创建一个游戏，逻辑是编程的基础。我们通常不考虑这一点。当我们想到编程游戏时，我们通常会想到我们已经讨论过的其他类型的游戏，即序列游戏，你在编程某个机器人做某事。但逻辑是非常基础的。我想出一个游戏，一个逻辑谜题，你知道，有点像数独，一个逻辑谜题，但线索是用“与”、“或”和“非”来表达的，也许还会进入更复杂的东西，比如“异或”、“当且仅当”、“与非”和“或非”。
What? You know, I mean, this is, and this is fundamental, not just a computer science, but this is how all math works, math proofs, scientific language. I mean, anytime you use or in a precise context, the inclusive or is assumed unless otherwise specified. So we really lead kids astray. And then as soon as you throw a not in there, I mean, when kids try to process double negatives, it takes them a while just to get that. But as soon as you start to say something like, well, just as a classic example, in programming, you might want to say, you know, X is between 1 and 5. So how might I do that? I might go, you know, 1 is less than or equal to X, and X is less than or equal to 5. Well, how do I not that? Well, I might, you know, the obvious way is i can put a knot around
我想做一个那样的谜题，你有一个基于这些逻辑连接词的线索系统，这样孩子们就可以在他们掌握如何推理所有连接词的过程中逐渐学习。这就是我着手要做的事情。我得到的灵感是在我阅读高德纳（Knuth）的晚期著作的时候。我不知道你的听众是否了解很多关于唐纳德·高德纳的事情，但他是一位了不起的计算机科学家，他开创了许多程序员每天使用的基础算法，他写了一本名为《计算机程序设计艺术》的巨著，这是他毕生的心血，他
that whole and expression but a lot of kids will get it wrong though they'll do like not x is greater than equal to one and not x is less five which is exactly what you don't want to do if you if you're not in the individual parts you need to change the and to an or. That's the Morgan's law. These things do not come naturally to kids just from thinking about it from English language. You kind of need to learn how to evaluate it, how to reason about it, and that kind of thing just takes practice. So I started from the premise of,
我想他现在已经80多岁了，他几乎一生都在致力于此。他写《计算机程序设计艺术》的热情非常高，以至于当第一份副本从排版员那里回来，看起来不像他想要的那样好时，他花了10年时间开发了LaTeX，以便让它看起来很好。但这本关于算法和思考算法方式的百科全书非常了不起。他至今仍在开发它。他仍在为这本书添加新的章节，每年或两年在亚马逊上发布。是的，他也有奖金。如果你能在他的书中发现错误，他的网站上实际上有奖金。我在上一本中错过了几天。
I want to create a game that is going, you know, logic is fundamental to programming. We don't usually think about that. When we think about programming games, we usually think about the other kinds of games we've already talked about, sequencing games, where you're programming some robot to do something. But logic is pretty fundamental. I want to come up with a game, a logic puzzle, you know, something kind of like a Sudoku, a logic puzzle, but where the clues are expressed in terms of and and or and not, and maybe getting into the more complicated things like XOR and if and only if and and and nor.
我想创造一款游戏，你知道，逻辑是编程的基础。我们通常不会这样想。当我们想到编程游戏时，通常会想到我们已经讨论过的其他类型的游戏，比如序列游戏，即你编写程序让机器人做某事。但逻辑是非常基础的。我想设计一款游戏，一个逻辑谜题，你知道，类似于数独那样的逻辑谜题，但其中的线索是用“与”、“或”、“非”来表达的，或许还会涉及更复杂的逻辑，比如“异或”、“当且仅当”、“与非”和“或非”。
I want to make a puzzle that does that, where you have a clue system based on these logical connectives so that kids can gradually, as they work their way through the mastery, over how to reason about all you connectives that's what I set out to do and and the the inspiration I got was around the time I was reading Knuth's late book I don't know if your listeners know a lot about Donald Knuth but he is a amazing computer scientist and a lot about donald knuth but he is uh a amazing computer scientist who's invented a lot of the pioneered a lot of the fundamental algorithms that programmers use every day and he wrote this tremendous book called the art of computer programming it's his life's work he's
我想制作一个这样的谜题，其中的线索系统基于这些逻辑连接词，这样孩子们在逐步掌握如何推理所有这些连接词的过程中，就能逐渐进步。这就是我着手要做的事情。我的灵感来自于我阅读高德纳（Knuth）那本巨著的时候。我不知道你的听众对唐纳德·高德纳了解多少，但他是一位了不起的计算机科学家，他发明并开创了许多程序员每天都在使用的基础算法。他写了一本名为《计算机程序设计艺术》的巨著，这是他毕生的心血，他
been i think he's in his late 80s now and he's been working on this almost his whole life uh he was so passionate about writing the art of computer programming that I think he's in his late 80s now, and he's been working on this almost his whole life. He was so passionate about writing the art of computer programming that when the first copy came back from the typesetter and it didn't look as good as he wanted, he took 10 years off to develop LaTeX so that he could have it look good. But it's this amazing compendium of algorithms and ways of thinking about algorithms. And he's still developing it to this day. He's still adding new chapters to this book that are released on Amazon every year or two. Yeah, and he has prizes, too. If you can find errors in his book, he actually has prizes on his website. I missed that by a few days on the last one.
我想他现在已经八十多岁了，几乎一生都在致力于此。他对于撰写《计算机程序设计艺术》充满热情，以至于当第一份排版稿出来时，他觉得效果不够好，于是花了10年时间开发了LaTeX，只为了让书看起来更美观。这是一部关于算法和算法思维的惊人汇编。直到今天，他仍在不断完善它，每年或每两年都会在亚马逊上发布新的章节。是的，他还有奖金。如果你能在他的书中发现错误，他的网站上确实有奖励。我上次就因为晚了几天而错过了。
I worked his latest chapter as soon as it came out, and I was reading through it, and a few pages into it, I saw some typo, and I was like, oh my goodness, I've got to write this. Because everybody, he sends the checks, I think they're $2.56 if I remember correctly, like a hexadecimal dollar calls it, to anyone who finds the first person to find each bug. And I get the impression most people don't even cash the check.
他的最新章节一出来我就开始研究了，读着读着，才过了几页，我就发现了一些错别字，当时我就想，天哪，我一定要写信告诉他。因为他会给第一个发现每个错误的人寄支票，如果我没记错的话是2.56美元，他称之为十六进制美元。我感觉大多数人甚至都不会去兑现那张支票。
They just frame it because it's such an honor to get it. And I saw this typo and I wrote in and I got back an email saying someone reported it three days before you but thank you but yeah I really his books I've gone back and re-read it maybe once every ten years or something and every time I because it's so dense like you read it and you understand some small fraction of what you're reading and even what you understand is already blowing your mind
他们只是把它装裱起来，因为能收到它是一种荣誉。我发现了这个错别字并写信过去，结果收到一封回信说，有人在你之前三天就报告了，但还是谢谢你。是的，我真的很喜欢他的书，我每隔十年左右就会回去重读一遍，每次读的时候，因为内容太密集了，你读了之后只能理解其中的一小部分，而且即使是你理解的那部分也已经让你大开眼界了。
and each time i read through it i get something different out of it because i'm at a new stage as a programmer i know more and i i have a different perspective on things so i go back every 10 years and kind of reread it and learn a whole new set of things that I didn't even notice before because I wasn't at that level before. So it's a really phenomenal series of books that you can learn a lot from. But I got the latest, his latest chapter
每次重读我都有不同的收获，因为我作为程序员处于一个新的阶段，我知道得更多，对事物的看法也不同了，所以我每隔10年就会回去重读一遍，学到一整套我以前甚至都没注意到的新东西，因为我以前还没达到那个水平。所以这是一套非常了不起的书，你可以从中获益良多。但我拿到了他最新的章节，
is about the Boolean satisfiability problem. The Boolean satisfiability problem. The Boolean satisfiability problem is a famous NP-complete problem. And the basic idea is you have a logical formula built out of a bunch of variables, and it's either the variable by itself or the variable with a not on it. And you have some logical expression out of these variables
是关于布尔可满足性问题的。布尔可满足性问题。布尔可满足性问题是一个著名的NP完全问题。基本思想是，你有一个由一堆变量组成的逻辑公式，它要么是变量本身，要么是带有非运算的变量。你有一些由这些变量组成的逻辑表达式，
and nots connected with and and or. There's kind of a normal, what they call a conjunctive normal form, which is a standard way to express. This is like two sat versus three sat. Exactly. Yeah, yeah. Yep. So there's different, but the general problem is still NP-complete.
以及用与和或连接的非运算。有一种常规的，他们称之为合取范式，这是一种标准的表达方式。这就像是2-SAT和3-SAT的区别。没错。是的，是的。所以有不同的形式，但一般问题仍然是NP完全的。
It's that there are some more precise subsets that are easier to prove that they're NP-complete. But the basic problem is you got this logical formula and you have to find which combination of trues and falses for assignments variables make this overall formula come out to be true and i was reading this and and this is in a recent talk he kind of said that he thinks that satisfiability problem is something that every programmer should have in their toolbox and one of the reasons behind that is because there's a lot of state-of-the-art research that has gone into writing these SAT solvers. And I was talking before about declarative modeling of problems. Like you've got some really hard problem you want to solve. Instead of writing the logic to solve it, it's great if you can figure out a way to express that clarity and just pass it to a fast solver. So it turns out because these are NP, you know, it's an NP complete problem.
有一些更精确的子集更容易证明它们是NP完全的。但基本问题是，你有一个逻辑公式，你必须找到变量赋值的真假组合，使这个总公式的结果为真。我读到这里时，他在最近的一次演讲中提到，他认为可满足性问题是每个程序员都应该掌握的工具，原因之一是目前在编写这些SAT求解器方面有很多最先进的研究。我之前谈到了问题的声明式建模。比如你有一个非常难的问题想要解决，与其编写逻辑来解决它，不如找到一种方法来清晰地表达它，然后将其传递给一个快速求解器，这会很棒。事实证明，因为这些是NP，你知道，这是一个NP完全问题。
What that means is that there's all these other NP complete problems, every NP complete problem, we often know the mapping of how that can be mapped to the satisfiability problem, because that's how you prove something is NP complete. You show it can be reduced in polynomial time to some other NP complete problem. So we have these mappings where we know, like, if I have this crazy hard problem, I could turn it into this satisfiability problem. It's kind of like, I mean, a good analogy here is, maybe it's not that good, I should move it up. This might be terrible, actually, but kind of like a socket wrench, right?
这意味着还有所有其他NP完全问题，每个NP完全问题，我们通常都知道如何将其映射到可满足性问题，因为这就是证明某事是NP完全的方法。你证明它可以在多项式时间内归约到某个其他NP完全问题。所以我们有这些映射，我们知道，如果我有一个极其困难的问题，我可以把它变成这个可满足性问题。这有点像，我的意思是，这里的一个很好的类比是，也许它不是那么好，我应该换个说法。这可能很糟糕，实际上，但有点像套筒扳手，对吧？
Like if you go to Home Depot and you buy, you know, a socket wrench, so you buy, you know, the top of the wrench, you buy all these bits, you might have like 30 bits, right? And you put that in your toolbox. And you have sort of some level of confidence that when you need to take apart like your kid's tricycle or something, that's either going to be, you know, an Allen wrench, sorry, you're either going to need like an Allen screwdriver or a phillips head or a flathead but that there's that there's all these kind of standard forms and there might be different sizes but you bought this one tool that can solve you know 99 percent of it right and so you just buy that tool from home depot put in your toolbox and you just take it
就像你去家得宝买一个套筒扳手，你买扳手的头部，你买所有这些钻头，你可能有30个钻头，对吧？你把它放进工具箱里。你有一种信心，当你需要拆开你孩子的自行车之类的东西时，要么是内六角扳手，抱歉，要么是需要十字螺丝刀、一字螺丝刀，但有所有这些标准形式，可能尺寸不同，但你买了这一个工具，就能解决99%的问题，对吧？所以你只要从家得宝买那个工具放进工具箱，然后你就可以把它
out whatever you need to and and so mpcomplete problems are kind of like that class where they're all sort of variants. It's very easy to go from one to the other because it's some kind of size change or some minor tweak. And so something that's really, really good at solving one of them can kind of solve all of them. Right. And the Boolean satisfiability problem is like your 99 tool like you said it's it's intimately connected to these empty complete problems so i was reading about this he has this whole new chapter of his book devoted to uh understanding how state-of-the-art sat solvers are actually built and walking you through the algorithms that drive these solvers and it's really fascinating stuff but as i like simulated and healing genetic algorithm type stuff or or what um
拿出来用。所以NP完全问题就像那一类问题，它们都是某种变体。从一个问题转换到另一个问题非常容易，因为只是某种规模的变化或微小的调整。所以，某种非常擅长解决其中一个问题的东西，几乎可以解决所有问题。没错。布尔可满足性问题就像你的99号工具，正如你所说，它与这些NP完全问题紧密相连。所以我正在读这个，他书中的整个新章节都致力于理解最先进的SAT求解器是如何构建的，并带你了解驱动这些求解器的算法，这真的很迷人。但是，就像模拟退火、遗传算法之类的东西，还是什么？
i he touches on there are some random processes that will get you there uh for certain classes of problems but that's not the the this that's not the state of the art as far as I understand. Oh, cool. I'll have to read it. I'll have to check it out. At least not for these particular satisfiability problems. Yeah, it's a really wonderful... And of course, Knuth is famous for literate programming, which is a form of programming where every bit of code is wrapped in a lot of very clear explanatory text explaining how this code works. And Knuth is the inventor of that style and the master of that style.
他提到了一些随机过程，对于某些类别的问题可以让你达到目的，但据我所知，那不是最先进的技术。哦，酷。我得读读看。我得去看看。至少对于这些特定的可满足性问题不是这样。是的，这真的很棒……当然，高德纳以文学编程而闻名，这是一种编程形式，每一段代码都被包裹在大量非常清晰的解释性文本中，解释这段代码是如何工作的。高德纳是这种风格的发明者，也是这种风格的大师。
And this new chapter basically reads like a literate programming version of a state of the art SAT solver so that you're reading through this program and understanding how it works. It's a really fascinating read. But as I was reading this, I thought, you know, I can make a game out of this. I think I see how I can make a logic puzzle built on top of the satisfiability problem. And if I do that, that will also serve the other purpose I talked about of a clue system that can be expressed in terms of and and or and not and get kids really comfortable with reasoning about these logical expressions. So the basic concept of the game is you're looking at a map of a robot brain and it's a bunch of nodes
而这一新章节读起来基本上就像是一个最先进SAT求解器的文学编程版本，所以你在阅读这个程序时就能理解它是如何工作的。这是一本非常引人入胜的书。但当我在读的时候，我想，你知道，我可以从中做一个游戏。我想我明白如何基于可满足性问题制作一个逻辑谜题了。如果我这样做，它也将实现我之前谈到的另一个目的，即一个可以用与、或、非来表达的线索系统，让孩子们真正习惯于推理这些逻辑表达式。所以这个游戏的基本概念是，你正在看一张机器人大脑的地图，它是一堆节点，
connected by these colored wires and the idea is you have these power cells and when you put the power cell on a node it activates all the colored wires that are touching it on the other on the the other page of the puzzle there's so you're looking at the map and then you're looking at the clue system. There's a clue system, which is a big logical formula about which wires need to be active or inactive. And from those clues, you need to figure out where to place the power cells. So the key here in the, it's almost exactly like the Boolean satisfiability problem in the sense that in the Boolean satisfiability problem, you have a formula, you're trying to figure out which variables are true and false. If this were exactly like the satisfiability problem, the equivalent would be, I have this
由这些彩色电线连接，想法是你有一些电池，当你把电池放在一个节点上时，它会激活所有接触它的彩色电线。在谜题的另一页上，你正在看地图，然后你正在看线索系统。有一个线索系统，这是一个关于哪些电线需要激活或不激活的大型逻辑公式。根据这些线索，你需要找出放置电池的位置。所以这里的关键是，它几乎和布尔可满足性问题一模一样，因为在布尔可满足性问题中，你有一个公式，你试图找出哪些变量是真，哪些是假。如果这完全像可满足性问题，等价物就是，我有一个
formula about which wires are on or off, and you need to figure out which wires are on or off. But I added one level of indirection, and that was like the secret sauce to make this a fun game, as opposed to feeling like just an exercise. And the secret sauce is you can't directly control whether the wires are on or off. You can only control them by where you place the power cells. So you're solving the logical formula, but you're also the puzzly aspect because you're trying to figure out where to place the power cells. And the topography of how the wires are connected to one another comes into play as well, not just the... It would be very dry if all you were doing is cranking through the logical implications of the formula.
关于哪些电线开启或关闭的公式，你需要找出哪些电线开启或关闭。但我增加了一层间接性，这就是让这个游戏变得有趣的秘诀，而不是感觉像是一个练习。秘诀在于你不能直接控制电线是开启还是关闭。你只能通过放置电池的位置来控制它们。所以你是在解决逻辑公式，但你也有解谜的方面，因为你试图找出放置电池的位置。电线如何相互连接的地形也发挥了作用，不仅仅是……如果仅仅是推导公式的逻辑含义，那会非常枯燥。
But the puzzles are designed in such a way that you have to go back and forth between kind of analyzing the formula and then going over and placing what you can on the map and then figuring out, oh, you know, I've already placed a power cell here and I've only got one left. And that means this other wire is active and this one can't be active. And like using the partial knowledge you have to go back to the formulas and do some more logical deductions over there. So you're kind of going back and forth between making these logical deductions, doing some placements on the map. And that's what makes it a fun puzzle. Yeah. So depending on where you place it, you may turn one, two or three. I think three might be the most. But one, two or three I think three might be the most but one two or three different
但谜题的设计方式是，你必须在分析公式和在地图上放置你能放置的东西之间来回切换，然后弄清楚，哦，你知道，我已经在这里放了一个电池，只剩下一个了。这意味着另一根电线是激活的，而这一根不能是激活的。就像利用你拥有的部分知识回到公式中，在那里做更多的逻辑推导。所以你有点在进行逻辑推导和在地图上进行放置之间来回切换。这就是让它成为一个有趣谜题的原因。是的。所以根据你放置的位置，你可能会打开一、二或三个。我想三个可能是最多的。但一、二或三个，我想三个可能是最多的，但一、二或三个不同的
colors on so that's what you're talking about is that you have to be strategic and where you place you're not just simply saying red is on you're saying I'm placing at this node and this mode node makes both red and orange on exactly yeah and so up circuit for people who like you know logic puzzles this is this is the most logic-y of the three right it's not about sequencing it's not quite like the same as the others it's about logical formulas i i don't know about you but i grew up on raymond smullion puzzles are you familiar with raymond smullion no i haven't heard that oh he was he he died recently but he was this famous logician who wrote all these books
颜色开启，所以这就是你所说的，你必须有策略地放置，你不仅仅是简单地说红色开启，你是说我把它放在这个节点上，这个节点使红色和橙色都开启。没错，是的。所以对于喜欢逻辑谜题的人来说，这是三个中最具逻辑性的一个，对吧？它不是关于排序的，它和其它的不太一样，它是关于逻辑公式的。我不知道你怎么样，但我是在雷蒙德·斯穆里安的谜题中长大的，你熟悉雷蒙德·斯穆里安吗？不，我没听说过。哦，他最近去世了，但他是一位著名的逻辑学家，写了所有这些书，
um with these puzzles about knights and knaves and knights always tell the truth and knaves always lie and there would be some combination of statements of a you know the person a says make some statement about b and b make some statement about a and they'd be, you know, some kind of logical statement like A is a knight or B is a knave. And you're told some kind of meta knowledge, like exactly one of them is a knight and the other two are knaves or something. And you have to kind of figure out what each person is. And like one of his first books i think was called what is the name of this book uh two of my favorite books of his are the lady or the tiger and alice in puzzle land which is a whole series of puzzles based on alice in wonderland material um but i grew up on these
关于骑士和无赖的谜题，骑士总是说真话，无赖总是撒谎，会有一些陈述的组合，你知道，A说关于B的陈述，B说关于A的陈述，它们会是某种逻辑陈述，比如A是骑士或B是无赖。你被告知某种元知识，比如其中一个是骑士，另外两个是无赖之类的。你必须弄清楚每个人是谁。他早期的书之一我想叫《这本书的名字是什么》，我最喜欢的他的两本书是《女郎还是老虎》和《爱丽丝漫游谜题世界》，这是一整套基于《爱丽丝梦游仙境》素材的谜题，但我是在这些
puzzles and just loved solving these logic puzzles and And I'm trying to capture that kind of in a visual system here. And that really pushes the ability to read the different kinds of connectives. Yeah, I think this one was very obvious to me that when you play it, it's very clear how once someone figures out how this works,
谜题中长大的，非常喜欢解决这些逻辑谜题。我正试图在这里的视觉系统中捕捉那种感觉。这确实推动了阅读不同连接词的能力。是的，我认为这一点对我来说非常明显，当你玩它时，一旦有人弄清楚它是如何工作的，
how they would debug a broken if statement. That, you know, if you have this if statement with some complex ands and ors, like this would very much set them up for being able to understand that you have to sort of look at what has to be true, what can't be true, and sort of track down which variables are in what state, you know, sort of how to evaluate it so that pretty much covers the whole series of three games they just arrived in target today um these are going to be exclusive to target for the rest of the year i went over to my local target
他们就会明白如何调试一个损坏的if语句。你知道，如果你有这个带有复杂与和或的if语句，这会让他们为理解你必须查看什么必须为真、什么不能为真，并追踪哪些变量处于什么状态做好准备，你知道，某种程度上如何评估它，所以这几乎涵盖了整个三部曲游戏。它们今天刚到Target，这些游戏在今年余下的时间里将是Target独家销售。我今天去了我当地的Target，
today and showed up because i wanted to see them for myself they it says on the website they're in stock but when i got there the lady who was oh, we're actually rebuilding the toy game section. And a lot of them are still on pallets in the back. But I'll be unpacking it in a couple of days. Did you say this is my game? Well, my daughter was with me and she mentioned it. And the lady got kind of excited about that, that I was there to sort of see my games on the shelf. And she felt really bad that they were in the pallets in the back oh no i'll have to go
因为我想亲眼看看它们。网站上说它们有货，但当我到达那里时，那位女士说，哦，我们实际上正在重建玩具游戏区。很多还在后面的托盘上。但我几天内就会拆开包装。你说这是我的游戏吗？嗯，我女儿和我在一起，她提到了。那位女士对此感到很兴奋，因为我在那里查看货架上的游戏。她对它们还在后面的托盘上感到非常抱歉。哦，不，我得过几天再回去亲眼看看。
back in a couple days to see it for myself but it's it's in stock at a lot of targets already it should like like my local target i'm expecting it to trickle to the rest as they set it up this week there are different displays um all three of these games are available. They're all priced at a retail price of $14.99, which is relatively inexpensive for this kind of thing. And some of that comes from the fact that these are unplugged games, too. A lot of the competing products out there, I mean, they're cool. They might have some kind of physical robot that zooms around or something but oh yeah but those those will cost two or three hundred dollars
但很多Target已经有货了，我预计随着他们本周的设置，它会逐渐推广到其他地方。有不同的展示，所有这三款游戏都有售。它们的零售价都是14.99美元，对于这类东西来说相对便宜。其中一些原因在于这些也是无需插电的游戏。外面很多竞争产品，我的意思是，它们很酷。它们可能有一些会四处移动的物理机器人之类的，但哦，是的，但那些要花两三百美元，
right because you got yeah and i think it's good to have it this way too because i think it's too easy to be distracted with the other ones and just you know sort of play with it and i think this yeah you this is forces you to do the mental processing of playing the computer which is what i was saying I think is the key skill. So yeah, I think you get a lot out of this. Kids already spend so much time on iPad and TV and things like that. Yeah, I've totally turned into my dad. I mean, when my dad would tell me to get off the computer,
对吧？因为你有……而且我认为这样也很好，因为我认为太容易被其他东西分心了，你知道，只是玩玩而已，我认为这迫使你进行玩电脑的心理处理，我认为这是关键技能。所以是的，我认为你从中学到了很多。孩子们已经花太多时间在iPad和电视等东西上了。是的，我完全变成了我父亲。我的意思是，当我父亲告诉我离开电脑时，
I remember, and we all probably remember this saying, oh, when I become a parent, I'm going to let my kids, you know, play on the computer all day long. And then sure enough, like the cycle just repeats, right? Like you can't, you know, you grow older and you realize like that's just not a very, you know, healthy environment. And so it's really good to have something that's tangible, physical, that isn't glowing black at you that you can play. Yeah, as a parent, I definitely got to the point where I started looking for unplugged things for my kids, things that wouldn't use up precious screen time. And my experience is I found that kids often have a very different kind of attention span on the computer versus physical things. Like on the computer, we are so used to clicking so fast as we navigate
我记得，我们可能都记得这句话，哦，当我成为父母时，我会让我的孩子整天玩电脑。然后果然，循环又重复了，对吧？就像你不能，你长大后意识到那不是一个非常健康的环境。所以拥有一些有形的、物理的、不会对着你发光的、你可以玩的东西真的很好。是的，作为父母，我确实到了开始为我的孩子寻找无需插电的东西的地步，那些不会消耗宝贵屏幕时间的东西。我的经验是，我发现孩子们在电脑和物理事物上的注意力跨度通常非常不同。就像在电脑上，我们习惯于在浏览网页时点击得那么快。
through the web. And, you know, anything that comes on the screen, we want to be able to click in two seconds or we get bored. And I was finding that if you show a puzzle or something like that on a computer screen, kids don't want to take the time to solve that. They just want to click on something within a couple seconds. But you set up a puzzle in physical fashion and put it in front of them and they get engrossed in it and they'll spend hours sitting there and kind of working through puzzles. And they're much more willing to work and try different combinations to solve a really hard puzzle that's my personal experience working with different kids yeah well we're running pretty long this is a long show no no it's okay um so i yeah i think it's very cool you know talking to someone who's designed games you
而且，你知道，屏幕上出现的任何东西，我们都想在两秒钟内点击它，否则我们就会感到无聊。我发现如果你在电脑屏幕上展示一个谜题之类的东西，孩子们不想花时间去解决它。他们只想在几秒钟内点击某些东西。但你以物理方式设置一个谜题并把它放在他们面前，他们就会沉浸其中，他们会花几个小时坐在那里解决谜题。他们更愿意工作并尝试不同的组合来解决一个非常难的谜题，这是我与不同孩子合作的个人经验。是的，好吧，我们时间很长了，这是一个很长的节目。不，没关系。所以是的，我认为这非常酷，你知道，和设计游戏的人交谈，
know that's always been interesting to me we all grew up playing games and solving puzzles think it's very cool, you know, talking to someone who's designed games, you know, that's always been interesting to me. We all grew up playing games and solving puzzles. So it's great to hear a lot of the insight you've given us about sort of how games get made, how puzzles get solved and rated. That's, you know, all enormously fascinating to me. So I very much appreciated your time. Well, it's been a pleasure. Is there you have any final questions for me?
这对我来说一直很有趣。我们都是玩着游戏、解着谜题长大的。所以听到你给我们的关于游戏是如何制作的、谜题是如何被解决和评价的见解，这非常棒。这对我来说非常迷人。所以我非常感谢你的时间。好吧，这是我的荣幸。你还有什么最后的问题要问我吗？
Where is it? Oh, go for it. Yeah, I was gonna say, yeah, give us a plug for, you know, well it's been a pleasure do you have any final questions for me? where is oh go for it give us a plug for ThinkFun's website has the games the code series on the brink robot repair and rover control where else can people
它在哪里？哦，尽管问吧。是的，我本来想说，给ThinkFun的网站打个广告，上面有游戏，Code系列，On the Brink，Robot Repair和Rover Control，人们还可以去哪里了解你在做什么，你在忙什么，或者了解更多关于你的信息？
go to sort of find out about what you're doing what you're up to or learn more about you? Yeah, and also where can people go if they're not in the US or Canada or wherever there's a target? Where else can people go to pick up the games? Well, that is the challenge
是的，如果人们不在美国或加拿大，或者没有Target的地方，人们还可以去哪里买这些游戏？嗯，这就是第一年作为Target独家销售的挑战。它最终会进入其他国家，但我不知道它的可及性如何。哦，明白了。好的。我不确定这个问题的答案。当然。
with it being a Target exclusive for the first year. It will eventually get to other countries, but I don't know how accessible that is. Oh, got it. Okay. I'm not sure the answer to that. Sure.
但我确实知道像Codemaster，在Target销售一年后，它现在已经进入了许多其他国家。所以这种情况会随着时间的推移而发生。哦，酷。所以他们可以从那个开始。他们可能还买不到这三款新游戏。好的。我实际上最近参加了一个棋盘游戏大会，一位来自德国的棋盘游戏设计师，因为很多伟大的棋盘游戏都是在德国设计的，他当时在那儿，我无意中听到他在我旁边的桌子上说，你知道，哦，我得跑去Target，因为我在美国，我可以去给我的孩子们买Codemaster。
But I do know like Codemaster, after its year at Target, it's now made its way to a lot of other countries. So that does happen over time. Oh, cool. So they can start with that. They might not be able to get these new three games just yet. Okay. I actually, I was at a board game convention recently and a board game designer from Germany, because a lot of the great board games are designed in Germany, was over here and I overheard him at a table next to me saying, you know, oh, I got
哦，那太棒了。我对此感到非常高兴。至于寻找我宣布的其他事情，我在Twitter上的名字是Mark_Engelberg。那是M-A-R-K下划线E-N-G-E-L-B-E-R-G。我不怎么发推文，但我尽量发，你知道，比如如果我有新游戏发布，或者如果我在Closure会议上做了演讲，我会把视频发在那里之类的。所以如果人们对我说的话感到兴奋并想关注我在做什么，这是一个很好的方式。非常好。非常酷。
to run out to Target because I'm in the US and I can go get Codemaster for my kids. Oh, that's awesome. I was really happy about that. So as far as finding other things that I announce, I'm on Twitter as Mark underscore Engelberg. That's M-A-R-K underscore E-N-G-E-L-B-E-R-G. And I don't tweet a whole lot, but I try to tweet, you know, like if I've got a new game coming out or if I gave a talk at a Closure conference and I'll post the video there or something. So it's a good way of if people were excited by what I talked about and want to kind of keep tabs on what I'm doing, that would be a great way to follow me. Very good. Very cool.
非常感谢你来到节目中。我想人们绝对会喜欢这个，或者已经喜欢上了。它触及了几乎每个人领域中的许多事情。现在进入该领域的人有了一个新的平台来学习和教导他们的孩子。所以谢谢你与我们分享这一切。这是我的荣幸。谢谢你邀请我。好的，谢谢，马克。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，
Thank you so much for coming on the show. This is I think people are absolutely going to love this or have loved this. It touches on so many things that almost everyone field. People coming into the field now have a new sort of platform to learn and teach their kids. And so thank you for kind of, you know, sharing all of that with us. It was a pleasure. Thank you for having me. All right. Thanks, Mark. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
但你必须注明我和帕特里克的出处，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。